okay so i'm going to go ahead and open
up today's uh hearings
uh for the education committee
um
see february the 9th
read the uh
okay
okay as chair of the house education
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covet 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 in the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the education committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held
please note that there is no fiscal
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem with accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email mcs ledge.state
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us today
jennifer 4 is our committee researchers
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll tall vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
uh madam clerk are you ready to go yes
uh good morning everyone representative
crowley
here in the committee room
representative boehm here in the
committee room
representative allan you're in the
committee
representative
here at home
and my husband may be in and out
i'm at the polling place with you guys
in my headphones
good luck and then i can hear thank you
representative sony
i am home family might be walking
through
representative miller
uh mira heath here in manchester
substituting for mel miller today and
i'm here in manchester at home and my
husband's in the other room
thank you mary
represent bluno erin hopkinson
representative shaw here at in the
committee room representative cornell
here at home in manchester all alone
representative tanner
uh here in georges mills sunapee um with
my dog uh raven
representative ellison
uh here alone in my home in concord
representative mullen
here in the basement in bedford alone
representative woodcock
here in center conway with my wife and
my dog which made bach occasionally
ben samuel
i'm here in the lobby
i was trying to figure out
i i thought i thought representative lay
up there but i don't see him okay
okay thank you it's like every every
morning here is a monday
i know it's tough
okay thank you very much everybody uh
just a note for all members on the
committee if you are going to be writing
a committee report either for the
majority of the minority we've been
asked to try and get all those reports
that have previously been done i think
we're only 53 and i will contact those
individuals who may be responsible for
getting
committee reports to us uh as we get
through here and and um
especially on thursday when we get to
the
uh executive sessions
be prepared hopefully to have some of
your committee reports uh put together
so we can get those to jennifer for as
quickly as possible
so with that i'd like to go ahead and
open up today's first hearing and that
bill is hb 136 requiring schools to
update documents and software to include
the option of identifying a student as
non-binary
representative woodcock here's the time
to sponsor that bill welcome
thank you mr chair good morning um
representative shaw for the record i
will send you my comments to save you
from trying to do note-taking
um my name is steve woodcock and for the
record once again i represent conway
eaton chatham and kale's location
uh thank you for the opportunity to
introduce hp 136
but more specifically mr chair with your
permission and to save time i'd like to
go straight to the amendment
0632h which was distributed by all s to
all members on the committee on friday
march 5th at 8 11 am
so hopefully they all have that there
representative ladd
is so
in order to provide context to this bill
i'd like to bring us
the new members up to speed and remind
those that were
here on the committee last session
that this bill or a similar bill
formerly hb 1163
and to which we heard much debate
as well as representative cordelli's
amendment 0849h
which the intent is ingrained in this
bill
both went to interim study for the
purpose of allowing doe to provide an
accurate assessment of what if any costs
would be exist for this bill's
implementation
the purpose of this bill
is to clarify that the parent or
guardian has the right to determine the
child agenda for the purpose of school
records
and more importantly
to allow no no to require
that schools be proactive
by providing a record system that allows
staff
to use the current correct pronoun for
student
this bill came about last year on a
request from a parent rebecca nan
who has submitted written testimony but
unfortunately i will not be here today
to speak in person
i met rebecca a few years ago at a
seminar
put on by my local library
and that seminar focused on the many
implications issues
and discrimination
that parents and children faced
as members of the lgbt community
and as you may imagine they were
numerous
so after the meeting i spoke with
several of the presenters regarding what
i or
we the house of representatives could do
to help
i was not looking for a laundry list but
rather one or two critical things that
we could do to make a child's school
experience
more healthy productive and safe
rebecca told me the story
the story of her child and the
discrimination that had to be incurred
regularly often annually to be specific
every year where a child changed grades
and had a new set of teachers
i'm not suggesting no issue
that the teachers the school
administration created this horrible
situation purposely
no
i'm presenting you the fact that
due to the schools antiquated system of
record-keeping and identification
the school became a partner
inadvertently and often unknowingly
providing the ammunition for bullying
harassment and discrimination in that
school building
we continue to hear in this chamber that
bullying is an extremely painful
experience
that negatively impacts the child and
family
and at a time it's often for years and
sometimes lifetimes
we hear about the families moving on
wanting to change schools
for the sole purpose of finding a school
that will provide a safe space
for meaningful learning
i am not here
to ask you to dive into the deep in the
pool
take a huge risk
or ask you to abandon your own lifelong
and historical understandings of what
you may believe as regards
the traditional roles of male and female
or for you to agree
with the parents determination or their
rationale
for requesting a non-binary
identification for the child
that is not
our responsibility
that is the parents
what this bill does and what you can
assist with
is to provide
relief for families
provide relief for children
and reduce the opportunity for in-school
bullying and discrimination which is a
result
of an outdated system of school record
keeping
hb 136
allows for
in on an annual basis
and or during the initial registration
period
oh
hold on mr chair
whoo thank you pie now mr chair my
battery was running low uh in the
computer i'm doing fine um
anyhow so what
allows the parents to identify the gen
of the child from school replicating
as miss nan wrote in her testimony often
her child was awfully incorrectly
addressed
for example when a substitute teacher
did not know how to correctly address a
non-binary child during attendance or
record keeping
or during iap meetings or parent-teacher
report conferences
these painful experiences were not a
human error
they were the result of not using
current technology
and the first step to alleviating that
cause
of this child's pain is to require the
updating of current school records which
hb 136 does by requiring
one additional keystroke
we hear it during hb
1163 that currently small systems
often change their record systems
for one purpose or another
by doing an in-house no-cost workaround
we also heard that the larger systems
also could easily change their computer
system at no cost because there is a
clause in their contract that provides
if the law changes the provider will
upgrade the system at no cost
doe estimated last year during the
interim study that the changes if needed
at the oe may require around 20 000.
that is all
hb 136
does is request the option for parents
made by a simple
software upgrade
how many times this year have we heard
it's about the parents let the parents
decide they know better
finally
this isn't the first as some of the
written testimonies acknowledged which
you've read i'm sure
the manchester school board has a policy
now in place and i quote
the student has the right to be
addressed by a name or pronoun that
corresponds to students gender identity
folks this isn't rocket science or a
complex task
is a simple software update
and rewind that accordingly will improve
the culture in our public and charter
schools
thank you for the opportunity to present
136 mr chair
and i ask all of us that we set aside
our personal feelings
and make a decision which is in the best
interest of parents and students thank
you
thank you very much uh representative
woodcock are there questions from the
representative
cordelli
mr chairman um
last year with uh house bill 1163
uh we had testimony from the department
uh in regard to the systems
and uh i believe it was uh stated that
there were approximately 15 different
software systems uh you know districts
and some additional homegrown systems
in addition to multiple major systems
within the department of education
so i'm just
wondering uh what is the basis
uh for
your prior statement that these are
simple uh software changes
uh thank you representative cordelli for
the for the question
um going back to the exact testimonies
you discussed
uh the superintendents
in testimony last year that came to the
education
committee session in person
those that were from small systems said
they already do many workarounds for all
kinds of computer programs by their i.t
people at no cost
and there was one or two superintendents
there last year from larger municipal
systems that said because of the
contract of the language with their i.t
provider that if it is a law
then their i.t provider will make that
change with no cost
further questions
uh represent whitcock i have i have one
question uh i'm i looked up at your
mending language um
and
the question i have is
regarding that
upon request from the parent or the
guardian
if a student is 19 years old can the
student make that request
yes could they be considered an adult at
that point representative led
okay i just i was just looking for
clarification whereas it didn't say that
within within your um
well the guardian a parent wouldn't have
an obligation after 18
in the school the school has the student
has the right to self-designate after
18.
i understand that thank you
further further questions of
representative whitcock
uh representative thank you um
um
what if the system
um that we're talking about one of their
narrative systems has a field called sex
would the
definition of that field have to be
changed
to mean
gender rather than sex
if i and you're coming through uh poorly
it may be my computer representative
cordelia but if i understand the
question correctly you're asking if if
there is an additional field the navy's
negated uh
in the programming currently there are
two fields typically biological fields
uh male and female this would be a third
field and that would be the addition in
the uh software programming for the
designation non-binary by the parent
thank you very much are there further
questions for our representative
woodcock
not seeing anything very much thank you
mr chair
who is next
can you hear me yes we can
all right thank you mr chair and members
of the committee for taking my testimony
today my name is sophia biandulilo i'm
14 i live in manchester
and i'm speaking today on behalf of new
hampshire high school democrats in
support of hp 136.
hb 136 is a really simple bill that i
think will be very beneficial for
non-binary and gender non-conforming
students
by allowing students to be properly
identified unofficial documentation in
school we promote understanding and
acceptance between teachers and students
and prevent bullying or other stressful
experiences
that might stem from a student being
improperly identified on their paperwork
i can't give any specific statistics on
how many non-binary students we have in
new hampshire but i can say that as a
gender non-conforming student who has
many non-binary friends and is aware of
many more outside of those i know
personally there is definitely a
significant population within our
schools
as for the financial implications of
this bill i think that due to the
simplicity of the change and the lack of
a fiscal note on the bill this will
probably have very little impact it
would just be a matter of adding one
more checkbox to a form or adding a new
option to a drop down
and if x versus gender is an issue that
would also just be a matter of changing
one word on an indicator
many institutions are already doing this
and we've seen the benefits to
non-binary people are great while the
cost is very very minimal
for all these reasons i think hp 136 is
a simple but very important bill that
would have great impact for non-binary
students and i asked the committee to
recommend auto-pass
thank you very much sophia are there
questions for sophia from
committee members
not seeing anything very much
uh do we have uh
amendment
well we do have uh from the department
uh dianna
uh could you upload diana's participants
does anybody have any kind of questions
thank you so much
can you give one to ralph
no this is 136 yeah
there's an awful lot of noise coming
from somewhere
i don't know if it's the people that are
in the lobby
with all the mics on or something but
i'm having a hard time i don't know if
anybody else is but i'm hearing a lot of
talking and
and not hearing the people who are
supposed to be talking sorry it probably
was me
ford just dropped off some amendments
for mr uh representative wilcox
amendments
i had trouble with uh representative
cordelli i couldn't understand half of
his uh testimony or
report
hopefully that helped
there are a couple people
that are um
good morning and thank you for having me
i'm actually uh playing the role of
caitlyn davis today so don't tell her
that i'm playing the role of caitlin
davis we'll just keep it a secret within
house education she'll never know um
thank you for having me caitlin was
unable to make it today
um so in terms of this bill obviously
the department does not take a position
for or against um but there would be a
financial implication of this bill we
would encourage there to be a fiscal
note on this um do we would have to
modify the student information system to
accommodate the
collection of of this new
area of non-binary
to do that we would have to pay a vendor
to
address the changes to the form
we would separately have to train
schools and staff
as to what this means how to implement
it how to collect this information how
to submit it to the department of ed
um
we would also have to go through our
current laws and our rules uh a lot of
them are ambiguous as to gender or sex
they use the terms uh interchangeably we
would have to look to see where that
would need to be modified
um
we would also have to work with all the
districts some of the districts would be
able to implement this uh their vendors
would pick this up would address this
change other schools would not so we
would have to spend some time working
with them ultimately just the need to
plan and modify that system
again
is it something the department
could do will do
if the legislation passes yes it is
but we would suggest that this bill have
a have a fiscal note to figure out how
this group would be reported out um
in its entirety i'm happy to take any
questions thank you for having me thank
you very much uh mr
questions
[Music]
thank you mr chair and good morning
attorney fenton
uh my question for you uh diana is are
you aware of any other times
that fields had to be changed in the
student information system
for any reason
thank you for the question
representative mullins nice to see you
um
i am not aware of that again that's not
an area that i work in on a daily basis
so let me do this let me
talk to caitlin davis and get you
an accurate answer to your question
has it probably happened in the past um
i would suspect it has but i i'm
hesitant to answer that question in the
affirmative so let me get that
information and circle back to you
that's great i just uh i appreciate it
my pleasure
are there other questions of attorney
representative
thank you uh thank you attorney thank
you for
system student information system
and
i recall from other
legislation
that they're actually
four five six other major systems
uh especially if he comes to moss
those
might also require update
gravity
thank you for the question
representative cordelli i i believe
you're corrected which is why we
referenced the
the idea that we would need to look at
our current laws and our current rules
and the other forms to see
how big this change uh will actually be
i think there are a lot of areas
where we would have to implement this
yes that is potentially the situation
and i did just get a
text message from miss davis to answer
representative mullen's questions
the answer is succinct it is yes we have
done those changes and it costs money
if you'd like any more detail than that
representative mom i'm happy to get you
that information as well
uh
mr chair commissioner who respond to
that
um
attorney fenton thank you so much for
providing that information and if you
wouldn't mind following up by asking for
uh an estimate on how much it cost that
would be great
i'd be happy to do that thank you
and and if i may i think this is why a
fiscal note would be prudent on this
bill
okay uh are there
is an attorney phantom
sure
enough
thanks very thanks very much mr chair
thanks very much attorney clinton um and
and unless you know the answer to to
this maybe this is another follow-up
request but the um the effective date on
136 in 60 days and um and obviously
that's from the time you know a law gets
signed by the governor but
i guess you know thinking practically
um you know we want to have things in
place at the start of the school year
would it be would it be practical would
it be possible for the department to
have things ready for the start of the
2021-2022
school year
whether that's
july 1st 2021 or september 1st 2021 if
we could have some um i think guidance
from the from the department as to when
those software changes any other
policy changes or rule changes
[Music]
implemented and in place
representative luna thank you so much
for the question um i
actually meant to address that in my
testimony so i very much appreciate you
bringing that up
the effective date as it stands in the
bill
would not be uh
workable for the department of ed we
would request at least a year in order
to implement these changes um these
changes are doable we have done these
similar changes in the past however i
think there it could have
wide reaching implications i think this
terminology that will have to be
addressed is in a lot of areas of the
work that the doe does
and we will have to work very carefully
with a vendor to implement these changes
we will have to work to change our forms
to train schools and to train staff
that's not to say we can't do it we just
have to recognize the lift that will be
on doe so again i appreciate the
question and i would request the um that
there be an amendment to reflect the
amount of work department would have to
do to
implement the terms of this bill and to
do it appropriately and not have it be
rushed
thank you very much attorney
uh are there further questions from the
committee members for the doe
not seeing the hands thank you very much
diana
thank you for having me enjoy the rest
of your of your day
up next um
listed we have christopher urgel um
scheduled to speak and i see a
christopher
in the attendees i'm wondering if this
is
christopher you've been um
[Music]
do you have yeah
okay next uh
from casey
good morning thank you thank you mr
chair and members of the committee my
name is jeannie herroska and i'm the
political director for the american
civil liberties union of new hampshire
i really appreciate the opportunity to
testify today in support of hb 136.
all students deserve accurate and
affirming documentation including those
who do not identify as male or female
for students who are non-binary being
stuck with m or f gender marker on
school documents is discriminatory and
can result in bullying and harassment
this discrimination can in turn trigger
the distress of gender dysphoria
managing this risk of discrimination can
also lead many transgender and
non-binary students to avoid
participating fully in the school
setting altogether
schools should be affirming spaces where
students are encouraged to be their full
authentic selves
we're encouraged by the growing number
of new hampshire schools that have
adopted policies that specifically
affirm trans students with manchester
being just the latest
and we support hp136 because the right
of non-binary students to be affirmed
should not depend on which school they
go to
in 2019 the legislature enacted sb 263
which provided public school students
with comprehensive non-discrimination
protections and implemented one of the
recommendations by the governor's
advisory council on diversity and
inclusion
since the enactment of sb263
public schools are legally prohibited
from discriminating against a student on
the basis of gender identity
if a school is required and able to
correct their records for a student
whose gender identity is male or female
it must do the same for a student who is
gender non-binary the alternative is to
blatantly discriminate against a student
who is non-binary and to deny who they
are
the notion that a person's identity is
not real because it is not binary
animates much of the discrimination that
non-binary people face
i i really listened closely to what the
department of education said
previously and i would just know
we believe that sb 263 quite frankly
necessitates this legislation and it's
concerning that there haven't been these
updates to software already to ensure
compliance with sb 263.
we were really proud of the legislature
when it enacted sb 263 a couple of years
ago and we strongly urge this committee
and this legislature to adopt hb 163 to
realize
the non-discrimination protections in sb
263 and with that i'm happy to answer
any questions
uh are there any questions of the person
testifying right now
in the aclu
not
thank you very much
thank you
uh so
uh
that's all that we've had scheduled to
testify
we do have several people in the
attendee list with their hands raised
so
would you like me to promote your
support
we have fancy west
this
zoom is playing games today people it
isn't i promise
okay go ahead
did you yes oh there she
you've got is
nancy west are you there
i think she's updated go ahead miss west
all right um
mr spear you've been promoted welcome to
education
okay thank you can you hear me
again
my name is steven scare 111 east hobart
street nashua new hampshire
education committee members thank you
for for taking my my request to speak
i beg you to reject hb 136 or any law
that denies biological truths about boys
and girls
and teaches the lie that any child can
be born in the wrong body
my niece was a brilliant but troubled
woman
who has bounced from house to house as
she was growing up
although she never had any signs of
gender dysphoria when she learned about
transgenderism she thought that would be
the end of her anxiety and her
depression and at first it seemed like
she was
when she announced that she was a boy
she became a local celebrity in her
school
and the cross-sex hormones made her feel
good at first
but as she grew older
she didn't want to move ahead with
further surgeries and she realized she
couldn't have her old body back
she was stuck with post-secondary sexual
characteristics
inclu including the the deep voice
she'd been talking about suicide and
then she died of an overdose shortly
before
this is happening all over the u.s
especially with young girls who have
trouble fitting in
girls on the autism spectrum and those
with anxiety disorders they're being
seduced by the the
trans craze and swept up by by
social media pure influence and
irreversibly damaged so please do all
you can to protect other young women by
rejecting any policy that forces other
people to pretend that a confused girl
is really a boy thank you very much
thank you very much for your testimony
stephen are there any questions for
stephen
not seeing any thank you very much
okay uh this west
if you're there there's still a
participant
just want to check
welcome to education
hello to honorable chairperson members
of the committee thank you i've been
here the whole time when i was called
earlier for whatever reason you couldn't
find me so i logged out and came back in
um my name is chris urchel i'm an
attorney with glbtq legal advocates and
defenders also known as glad we're new
england's go-to legal advocacy
organization for serving the lgbtq
community
i'm also a new hampshire licensed
attorney although i am based in boston
and i'm here to testify in support of
hb136
um i just want to address a few things
that came up um so far in the hearing
um first of all i have not seen the
amended language so i want to put an
asterisk that my testimony is in
reference to the bill language that's
available online
um i want to echo a really important
point that representative woodcock made
earlier which is that schools are going
out of their way
to right now to make workarounds to to
accommodate the needs of students
and to comply with their own policies
and to comply with uh with with the law
that genie kruska just described um
which requires non-discrimination and
those workarounds are
time intensive they require a lot of
attention from school administrators
they require people like me to show up
and meet with and talk through issues
with people at schools and so the real
expense is there okay i also want to
address the question about whether uh
there's a distinction between sex and
gender and the bill language that i am
familiar with the terms sex or gender is
what appears in the in the language of
the bill and um
and i want to make i want to emphasize a
point which is that there's no legal
significance between or no legal
significantly significant difference
between the terms sex and gender they're
used interchangeably and they're also
used interchangeably outside of the
legal context including in schools and
on school documents you'll find school
documents that refer to sex and
documents that refer to gender and
they're used interchangeably all right
also i want to take just a quick moment
to provide a little bit of a framework
for talking about who non-binary people
are because the terms unfamiliar to many
people the legal framework for talking
about non-very non-binary people is even
less familiar
so let's start with the more familiar
concept of transgender people
transgender people are people who are
assigned who's assigned sex or natal sex
doesn't match their gender identity and
virtually everyone is assigned to sex at
birth either male or female
and um for for uh for people who are who
who are transgender those don't line up
um that doesn't line up with their
gender identity and some people
experience a health condition known as
gender dysphoria so gender dysphoria is
a condition it's a serious health
condition it's recognized by the dsm-5
and it's defined as clinically
significant distress caused by the
mismatch between your assigned sex and
your gender identity so in other words
people who experience the health code
condition known as gender dysphoria are
generally speaking transgender people uh
and fortunately uh although gender
dysphoria is a very medical condition
it's also really highly treatable every
major medical association agrees on this
point everyone that the only appropriate
treatment for gender dysphoria is gender
transition so in other words
transitioning to live consistent with
your gender identity that's the only
treatment for the serious medical
condition known as gender dysphoria okay
and treatment is highly individualized
it involves any combination of different
treatment options for how a person
transitions but when we're talking about
children we're talking about social
transition okay
social transition and it's medical
treatment that that that that enables a
person to live in their day-to-day lives
consistent with their gender identity
okay and that inc includes going to
school and being recognized as your
authentic self but it also involves
something i like to refer to as legal
transition which means updating identity
documents and having you know
recognition that your name and the
pronouns that you use and the markers on
your identification documents are all
consistent with your gender identity
so um we typically think of transgender
people as transitioning from male to
female or from female to male but um as
we know there are other people who
experience gender dysphoria whose gender
identity is neither male nor female and
so the blanket term that we use to
describe these people is non-binary
so having set that stage i just want to
remind everybody uh you know this has
already been stated but just two
sessions ago new hampshire enacted a
comprehensive non-discrimination statute
that applies to all public schools
and the statute um includes protections
on the basis of race religion sex and
gender identity um
and among other things that law um
applies uh to prohibit discrimination
against non-binary students too because
that's their gender identity
also in 2019 another bill became law
that established the right for new
hampshire residents to obtain
identification cards and driver's
license that indicated gender other than
male and female so an x marker on new
hampshire identification forms indicates
that a person under the consultation of
a medical care provider has transitioned
to a gender identity that's outside the
traditional male female binary when you
take these laws together
it just leads to inescapable conclusion
that new hampshire public schools must
also recognize that some students have a
non-gender or non-binary gender identity
but new hampshire schools have already
gone further you know about half of new
hampshire students are already covered
under school district policies that
protect them from gender identity
discrimination in many cases explicitly
recognizing that some students are
non-binary or another term gender
non-conforming
universally nearly all of us agree on
all of us and everyone here on this
committee and everybody listening agree
on one important point which is that
every new hampshire public school
student must be granted equal education
opportunities and that's true regardless
of their gender identity and i know that
i know i know that equality is a really
important priority for every single
member of this committee
so non-binary students like all students
they must be affirmed in their gender
identity it's not just the decent thing
to do or the right thing to do it's also
the medically appropriate and medically
necessary thing to do
any medical care provider is going to
who's who's competent and respected is
going to tell you the same thing that
young people must be affirmed in their
gender identity this is true for
transgender students it's true for
non-binary students it's true for gender
non-conforming students
so hb 136 brings us closer to that goal
and it's a very simple and
straightforward manner it's not overly
prescriptive it simply directs school
software and paperwork to provide a
gender marker for students who identify
neither as exclusively male nor is
exclusively female and the schools can
take it from there uh and so can the
vendors frankly it's it's the
responsibility of the vendors that the
school contracts with to accommodate the
needs of the students that they serve
uh this bill is simple it causes no harm
to anybody
and it might mean a world of difference
to the health safety and well-being of
the students whose gender identity is
non-binary
schools already have this obligation to
treat non-binary students with respect
to treat them equally to be trained to
do so those obligations already exist
and this law doesn't change any of that
there's no justification for voting
against this bill and i strongly urge
everyone in the committee to vote ought
to pass
and i'm happy to take any questions
chris are there
questions
uh thank you ms chairman um
thank you for
being here
uh you mentioned
gender markers gender identities
and we've had testimony
in the past and other legislation
as to the
number of
different identities to which people
might identify
is
if we were making a software change is
there a a list
of valid identities
that um would be
uh put into a computer database that is
would that just be a one-digit code or
how would that how would that work do
you think
oh so i think that's a really important
question and thank you for raising it um
people's gender identities are any
number of things that people can
identify in any multitude of ways and uh
in fact um in fact language is
constantly evolving and changing so to
answer your question no none of that is
necessary it's not necessary to
accommodate every conceivable way that a
person might identify themselves what's
important is to recognize that some
students most students identify as male
or female and then some students don't
and those students deserve to
to be able to like have have recognition
of the fact that their gender identity
isn't encompassed by that male or female
binary as
conventions change and language evolves
uh there's there's no reason to
imagine that we need to identify every
single student exactly with the marker
that they identify as because we just
need to understand that not all students
identify as male or female what this
bill does is it says that there's male
gender students there's female gendered
students and then there are students who
are not either that's all
thanks thank you very much
our current partner representative
thank you mr chairman thank you attorney
rachel for taking my question
uh as you're probably aware there is
also de-transition and re-transition and
some youngsters
their identity changes uh
even if they're already binary so my
question is as you look at this
legislation
uh
if if the software is put in place would
it accommodate
a youngster who undergoes retransition
or detransition
well
i'm going to answer that by well first
just i want to say that you know that
you bring up the term detransition that
that that term actually applies to a
very very small number of people who go
through a medical transition and then uh
decide later that that is uh that that
is not what works for them in their
lives and in many cases the reason that
those people usually adults decide to
detransition is because they experience
great discrimination great levels of
discrimination as most transgender
people do uh operating in the day-to-day
world and therefore you know uh decide
that what's best for them is to
detransition and for those people they
have every right to do that but that has
nothing to do with what we're talking
about here what we're talking about here
is acknowledging students
based on how they identify with the
gender marker and if your question is
whether a student might change from m to
f and then to x
in the future uh yes that is something
that could possibly happen is that
disruptive or does that uh you know
interfere with the way school systems
operate no it doesn't this is a very
simple way to accommodate students who
are uh you know at an age when they're
learning to understand their gender
identity
thank you very much are there further
questions of mr herschel
thank you very much chris
thank you
welcome okay last hand i see is
good morning
my name is susan stearns and i'm the
deputy director for nami new hampshire
the national alliance on mental illness
i'm actually here in the place of our
executive director ken norton who was
called away
um on behalf of nami new hampshire i am
testifying in support of house bill 136
while i think many of us may feel of a
certain age many of us may feel that
the
visibility
of
this variety across the gender spectrum
seems relatively recent in our lives
what we really are seeing is that the
acceptance and the willingness for folks
especially young people to disclose that
variety on the gender spectrum is what
has changed it's not that that gender
spectrum didn't exist previously but
that acceptance is starting to come into
being
however even as we have greater numbers
of people who are disclosing their true
gender identity
it doesn't change the challenges that
many of our young transgender and
non-binary folks go through
um many youths who are transgender or
are non-binary are rejected um even by
the their immediate family
they are often bullied at school as we
have heard
and there is an alarming increase
of violence in our society against
transgender and gender non-conforming
individuals in recent years
which leads many youth to feel unsafe
because of this
oppression and lack of acceptance for
many of these young folks they are
indeed at greater risk of suicidal
thoughts and actions
research indicates
transgender people are twice as likely
to think about or attempt suicide than
individuals who identify with the sex
that they were
they were assigned at birth
one 2018 study by the american academy
of pediatric found an increased risk
level in transgender and non-binary roof
youth
that found the highest rates for
attempted suicide were by transgender
men in non-binary youth at 50.8 percent
and 41.8
respectively
while these statistics are disturbing
it's very important to note
that there are very simple things that
can be done to reduce these high
percentages and improve overall health
and well-being for these young folks one
of them are endeavors like house bill
there was a study performed at the
university of
texas at austin that found that when
transgender and gender non-conforming
youth were able to use their chosen name
the name they chose to identify identify
their true gender their risk of mental
health conditions and suicide decreases
in fact this study found that amongst
these youths who were able to use their
chosen name they experienced 71
fewer symptoms of severe depression a 34
decrease in suicidal ideation and a 65
percent decrease in suicide attempts
as the mother of a now
adult non-binary individual who once sat
in an icu
next to them after a suicide attempt
i can't tell you how it heartens me to
hear such simple things
might prevent another mother from having
to experience the same
the same thing
so if the simple act of allowing someone
to use their chosen name can reflect the
drastic improvement in mental health
maturely their ability to disclose the
gender identity on official documents
can make much the same impact we as
we've heard new hampshire now allows you
to do that on your driver's license and
efficient identification
surely schools where our children spend
the bulk of their time or
once this pandemic is over over we hope
they're back to spending the bulk of
their time
um is an important place for them to be
able to identify um as non-binary
transgender as their true authentic
selves
to a transgender or gender
non-conforming person the reflection of
their gender on official documents
and their
places can play a significant role in
their self-esteem and their emotional
well-being
naming new hampshire believes that the
passage of hb 136 is an effective step
for reducing suicidal thoughts and
behaviors
we ask you vote to pass
thank you thank you very much are there
questions for asterns
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you
with this uh we have no more folks to
testify on this bill so i am going to
close this hearing for hb 136.
uh do we have the number of folks the
data there um
uh
representative shaw maybe just double
check i have 254 in support
254 supporting 92 votes 92 opposed one
neutral one neutral and testifying
i have eight
and eight
thank you
um also mountain clerk i see that
representation is present so we can mark
him as here on the attendance yes
thank you very much
um also for the committee uh regarding
we've not closed 136
uh
i've been informed that
uh for us to gather a fiscal note and
we've been encouraged to do so by the
department of education
we need to have a committee
vote to do so requiring the lba to
get that fiscal note from the department
of education and if this is uh quoting
um an rsa
uh rsa
14 colon 46
roman 5 small a
roman 5.
small a
we can get that fiscal note quickly if
we take
a vote right now today
or we can delay it and and if we wanted
this to know which i believe we should
as a result of what uh attorney bentley
was uh suggesting
we could have a motion to
direct uh to request
a
fiscal in the lba
that's open to the committee now to
discuss
uh i will not discuss it too long but uh
because we have number bills but uh
that's the way it works uh rex on luna
is that hand up or down yeah no it's up
it's a parliamentary
inquiry of the chair
um
so thanks very much mr chair just
wondering what what the request of a
fiscal note would mean in terms of
um the status of um of
136 and given the fact that some house
deadlines have already come and passed
um if if um requesting a fiscal note now
would uh would somehow imperil um this
bill going forward
i i would suggest that it most likely
would not sing what mr woodcock rexella
would talk as mentioned that if there is
a cost factor it's probably very
insignificant
however
um
i think that that it will be determined
if we can get something from uh
caitlin davis as quickly as possible uh
i i can't see any reason why it should
not take long and we have a deadline for
these bills which has been extended to
get bills out
so if we get that back
we can uh
have that brought back to our attention
here and
have it available for an executive
session
so just to follow up on that mr chair um
just just to be completely clear um and
and you know i'm i'm
in the of the mindset here that that
let's get started on this now
um knowing that it's going to take a
little bit that it could take a little
bit of time to do i wouldn't want to see
this bill
in any way derailed uh procedurally so
should we get confirmation from the
clerk or the speaker's office that
that
getting a getting a fiscal note would
not create um
a problem
well to respond to that to that dave um
i i've just been informed by the lba
that wanted for them to do something
they have to have the committee
recommending that it be done seeing that
it's not something that's gone forward
out of committee yet
i would suggest that you know once uh
the next bill i have to testify 182 but
upon that i will immediately call
um the lba saying we have this committee
vote i'd like to have it sent directly
over to kingdom davis and having them
start working on it so we that gives us
a couple weeks here
to um
what's the date we have to have these
things done by
you know april 1st
so april 1st is a deadline to get that
in i believe that it can be done and i
will encourage them to do so seeing that
this bill i i understand the need
um
so i i guess that's all i can assure you
on right now
okay
thank you very much rick mr chair a
point of
point of uh inquiry
please
um
we've had other
really big bills come through
that have had no physical note to them
have nothing filled in
and the information that we were told
was that it would just go on to the
physical committee as a second committee
and could be decided there
and i'm wondering why all of a sudden
we have a bill
that
we need a definite number for why
why can't this just go through as
needing a fiscal note and let the
physical committee do it i mean i i
don't understand that well for one we've
gone by that early date we did uh
request fiscal notes on there was one
bill which we had on the added cost of
adequacy and as a result of getting that
late when we did get the fiscal note it
didn't work and that's why
uh it didn't go forward um i
i i
recognized that it should have had a
fiscal note most likely
and but it doesn't but now it's not
going to go into fiscal seeing that
those those issues are already been
dropped on their doorstep um i think
that if it comes back that this will
notify light which i it to be then we
can move forward and bills like that
where they're it's not a heavy duty
pistol no oftentimes not even set to uh
to physical for their review
so that that's where we stand on it
right now
so
what another question mr chair
yes go ahead
so thanks um so information that that um
that
i received
from from caitlin
davis back in september of 2020 and this
was specific to house bill 1163
which is which the same subject of of
this
ms davis estimates that it would take
around 20 000
um worth of contractor hours to update
the data collection reporting
warehousing
um systems at the um at the department
and that the um that the costs to um
to school districts
would uh would would really be de
minimis because um if the state requires
it then they will update the system free
of charge so that's the student
information systems on there i'm just
wondering if um if if maybe there's no
fiscal note because
of the um you know the relative
financial impact uh i mean i think we've
heard that below a certain bar
um the lba just doesn't doesn't do
fiscal notes and would it be sufficient
to to maybe get this information for the
committee to get this information
directly from ms davis since we know
they rely on the department for drafting
the notes
um
so that it doesn't so that so it
basically becomes information from the
department on the cost impact
um of this and this committee can make
um
you know can look at that uh when it
comes to executive session rather than
all of a sudden
this bill being retitled and retitled
within with an fn and um and potentially
having to go to a
a second committee um
after that deadline is passed
we
uh
we can do that we can go right to
caitlin and we've done that before
however when it comes time where there's
been a recommendation and the
recommendation was made by department of
education in this hearing
we can get that fiscal note rapidly
but we're not and lba will not accept uh
a fiscal analysis based upon what we get
from doe it's gonna unfortunately it's
gonna go true lba and provide it to us
that could be done quickly it's just i
offered that as an option here and to
expedite the bill um if we delay today's
work you know we're just slowing it down
i cannot i cannot request a uh
lba fiscal note
uh until we have gone through the formal
voting on it to request that as a total
commitment that's according to that rsa
that's what we were told already today
by lba
no i i get that mr chair i'm just
suggesting whether that's really really
necessary and if there's an alternative
more expeditious path giving the um the
the the twenty thousand dollar estimate
that i have in writing from miss davis
um uh
you know and the no cost to school
districts that that that would be a
better way to um a more
expeditious way to uh to proceed that's
all i'm suggesting
uh represent
your handout yes i do mr chair thank you
for taking um
my uh question
on a yearly basis the department of
education
normally has to do updates just based on
any number of things
it just seems a little bit unfair to
attach um one particular thing to a
separate fiscal note
in order to update a system
that usually
because of legislation passed during a
session year
they have to update anyway so it would
be my thought that this would just be
part of the usual and customary updates
that the department of education
normally has to do in the course of
doing business with the new hampshire
legislature thank you for taking my
question cornell thank you
looking back on my notes
house on
1163 last year
um the department also suggested that a
fiscal note be obtained and we had the
same recommendation uh just today
so uh i think that that is the uh
proper way to proceed and all it takes
is a committee vote and request to the
lba
okay sir uh anybody willing to put forth
a motion if not we will not have a
physical note
representative cordelia you have your
agenda yes thank you
that the house certification committee
um request
a fiscal note for
us bill 1160 number two
136 uh in accordance with rsa
14 colon 46 roman 5.
seven seconds
okay there's discussion on that now if
not uh
yes representative
you think you just
you know thank you
for the lattice it's breaking up
[Music]
thank you mr chairman i was just trying
to find out the initial part of
representing cordelia's
motion i couldn't hear i just want to be
accurate on it please if you have the
clerk repeat it
i i would like to move
that the house education committee
request a fiscal note on house bill
in accordance with rsa 14 colon 46
roman 5.
thank you reverend cordelia thank you mr
chair
thank you
further discussion yes represent tanner
uh thank you i just wondered if uh
represent our attorney fenton is still
here
she does
um i'd like to ask her a question if i
could about this
go ahead i think she's there
okay um we passed a bill that became law
uh 193 colon 38 that um
is a non-discrimination law
uh affecting public schools
i'm on some level i just i was just
thinking i'm surprised that
the department of education
didn't uh when that bill came through
uh and became law didn't actually update
their systems then i i uh heard uh
representative heath say that they they
update the systems regularly and it
would seem to me that they would have
done that
at that time uh
do you have any information about that
attorney fenton
thank you so thank you for the question
um i'm somewhat limited in information
because i am just testifying on behalf
of uh caitlyn davis as you know
um
i i don't know if we
do updates to our system
every year uh what i can tell you is
that um
we anticipate because we simply don't
have the software we would have to
contract with the vendor now we've done
that in other instances we would do that
um
in in this case if need be um i i'm not
sure representative tanner i missed part
of your question when i was being
updated to a panelist i'm not sure what
law you were referring to
if you could just repeat that sure uh
193 colon 38 it was uh went into law we
passed the bill
uh last term and um
it describes non-discrimination in
public schools and uh this bill
uh you know is just kind of a follow-up
with parents requests um i would have
thought that the state department of
education
would have updated their software
uh in response to a non-discrimination
bill like that um just just to protect
themselves from possible lawsuits
and i was wondering if we had any
information about whether they had or
had not thank you
thank you for the question and the
clarification to the best of my
knowledge
19338 did not require an update to our
systems i will double check on that to
make sure that i'm accurate in that
response
um it was in speaking with caitlin davis
she's the one who recommended that there
be a fiscal note just so we can really
flush out what this would look like
that suggestion came directly from her
and again i just want to reiterate we
have updated our
systems before we will continue to do so
i don't know if it's done annually but
certainly uh representative heath is
correct when there's legislative change
we certainly take that on um the
information i just wanted to convey to
the committee today was that we would
have to um
work with a vendor and and pay that
vendor to make those changes and to just
be cognizant that there would be other
fiscal implications just in terms of
training schools and staff
and just
the undertaking it would be
okay um further discussion from
representative
uh thank you mr chair this is a question
to um representative
representative to attorney fenton um
attorney fenton so
if the department is in the practice of
updating uh software and training on any
legislative changes that come out
um
has this issue ever been raised in the
past the cost of updating the software
i mean i i've been around for a few
years now and i i don't remember uh
addressing
the cost of updating the software of the
department based on any legislation
other than this
thank you for the question
it is always a concern for the
department in terms of us being aware of
what impact it will have on
on us internally it might be something
that we have become more aware of in
current years moving forward recognizing
that some of these changes do require
significant um undertakings um
so
you know internally it's something that
we have talked about representative
mullen does it always equate to a fiscal
note perhaps not that might just be more
of a best practices that we've
undertaken um
recently because sometimes what happens
is we will not and i'm not talking about
this bill in particular but in general
once the laws um are passed we then have
an opportunity to say oh okay what is
this going to require for the department
to do to effectuate this bill and as a
best practice we are now trying to
address those
earlier in the process
and identify what it will take um i will
just refer back to representative luna's
question of the effective date and
that's something that um again not in
this bill but in other bills has caught
us
sometimes to say gosh we need a longer
period of time a longer runway if you
will to implement this bill and so these
are some things the department is trying
to be more proactive on
identifying some issues as the
legislation works its way through the
system
to to say you know what we're going to
need more funding more support more time
here so that at the end we can implement
the bill as the legislature has
envisioned
thank you very much i'm going to not
have any more discussion on this we're
we're falling farther behind you on the
appearance today so we do have a motion
on the floor
and a motion is to in accordance with
uh rsa 114 column 46 uh roman 5
to
request from the lba
a fiscal note referencing hb 136.
i'm adam clark would you please call the
role representative cordelli
yes
representative allard yes
[Music]
yes
uh representative
okay i'll i'll i'll take it uh no
you're voting out for representation
representative luna was there for you or
her her representative yeah i mean i'll
i'll take it since i'm um
deputy ranking
no but she's muted
it's on her
i'm i'm i'm voting heath votes no
okay gotcha
um
representative shaw no
representative cornell no
representative tanner no
representative ellison
no
representative mullen
representative lay
no
representative woodcock no
representative lad yes
so basically what i'm going to do is um
i'm supposed to take the positive on
that and the positive would be to seek
a fiscal note
go ahead represent options yeah i was
just wondering who requested that this
one up in the first place i mean we
weren't talking about it in this video
so what what was the vote on that
1010.
motion fails 10 10 so motion fails
thai vote motion fails wow
okay so we will not see a
fiscal vote
yes
this is oliver ford i didn't get to vote
and i don't know whether it's something
to do with my computer or what
you're not visible
yes
i can't i'm having trouble with my
computer
and i suspect that somehow not having my
picture on the screen means i don't get
the vote
what was your name sir i
understood an answer of yes
he's correct
voted yes yes but that that will count
because you cannot see his image
right he's not serious i can see all of
you but you can't see me and i don't
know how to fix it
oh representative ford i sent you an
email if you check that and try to
follow those instructions um i think
you'll be able to to get sorted out
thank you
motion fails
uh we're going to go ahead with hb
uh 182.
i understand that you're talking
you'll open the hearing on health bill
182 relative to the approval of
coursework needed at other two schools
and uh let's recognize uh sheriff
to introduce the bill thank you very
much this is
uh for the record my name is rick ladd i
come from evil new hampshire and i'm
here to introduce and support uh hb 182.
we've we've heard this in the last
session this bill is coming back
modified and uh there is an amendment
which everybody should be in possession
of it's
0-6-9-0-8 and i will speak to that
amendment uh in the amendment if you're
looking at
approval of courses and programs
the principal or other administrator of
a high school shall grant credit toward
high school
graduation and that's read initially
for courses and programs completed at
other approved schools
the changes to that language
uh reads as follows the principal or
other administrator of a high school
shall grant credit toward high school
graduation for similar courses
and programs that have been
satisfactorily completed at other
approved schools or shall provide
reasonable justification for denial
that particular language those changes
is an exact replication
of what we have for students under the
military compact which we have
rsa 110
dash d colon eight
uh roman one
that language is exactly as it stands
there uh i did not include any of the
other language where they can be
appealed
or that it can be then you can have some
other kind of an assessment as we had in
previous years this simply says
that if it's
denied then uh reasonable justification
for the denial shall be provided
that's the only change to the bill
and for purposes of this section
approved schools include all new
hampshire public schools charter public
schools public academies approved public
or private tuition program schools in
all schools in vermont maine that are
members of the interstate school
district with schools in new hampshire
in other words the interstate compacts
which we have
so i'm going to conclude my presentation
because we are in a
time frame here
i think most of us are all familiar with
this language and the
intent of this bill from previous years
and and the changes come from current
statute for children of military
families thank you very much
thank you
chairman lad
i see
one hand so far representative ellison
thank you
and thank you representative for taking
my question
would this include the bill include
programs courses
uh that were authorized under the learn
everywhere program
and it says that complete and completed
at other approved schools
schools
um those courses as i see it are not a
school
okay
thank you welcome
uh
i do not see any other obsidian
representative
um thank you um
mr chair
um just looking at this bill and based
on what you just said
does
the principal of the school retain the
right
to deny
credit award
and my understanding from what you just
said that if in fact
the student does not agree they have the
right to appeal
does this change
allow the local school district to
retain their authority
is my question
okay um the appeal process that we had
in previous years is gone
what this does it basically says and
it's exactly what it says in the
military contract for kids for millions
that have been in eod schools or some
other location
that if the course is similar to a
course that's available that should help
the principal or that principal's design
to determine whether they're going to
give credit towards graduation based
upon the course we offer in the
receiving school
if you decide that it's not it does not
satisfactorily complete
what you have identified as your program
in your high school then it can be
denied
um but it doesn't say there's any appeal
process it shall provide reasonable
justification for denial in other words
to explain in the in this course in juta
it did not contain this this this and
this and that's something we have
reached in our course here
and or it might be that the principle or
designate provides some kind of
assessment they don't have to do that
and the child doesn't you know
achieve competency there's another
reason why
and that's reasonable
if i may mr chair
um could i just have a yes or no answer
with regard to the retention of the
authority of the local school district
over the awarding of credits is it a yes
or no
the the yes is for the school district
to determine whether they're going to
accept it or not accepted
thank you
representative
thank you uh representative cordelli and
thank you representative ladd for taking
my my question
um my question
this time around is the same as it was
the last time we dealt with this bill
and that is over the word program
different schools and different
personnel
define the word program
in specific ways
and i'm just wondering if you can
tighten for me the understanding of
what
this bill considers a program to be
is it a credit bearing program
or um i just i i
i feel like it's a little ambiguous and
i'm wondering what the definition of the
word program
is some programs are terms which are
used in the military compact as well
so we would be using the same
definitions that they use and
programs we know there's programs
oftentimes that are provided to protect
implementation systems
there
we have programs built into our advocacy
law
it would be basically the same
definition that exists in statute now
okay thank you very much
hey uh president tanner
uh thank you for taking my question
i was wondering
because i'm not that super familiar with
the military code
when
under their code do they accept
uh programs and credits from well it
wouldn't be credits but from schools for
tuition only
um
schools that don't have uh a formal
graduation or
uh
aren't accredited do they accept from
just anybody
i'm just a little bit lost in your
question in here uh the
for those of us which were here
years ago when the military compact was
put together this is the same used in 50
states across the country it's uh
it's common for those that have the kids
in independent schools or or the kids
are in a school that could be a public
school in the location where their their
mom or dad is in the military it could
be in europe someplace or africa in some
place and they transfer often and this
is trying to facilitate so kids don't
lose um
graduation credit or don't lose the time
otherwise you don't want to see kids in
school having to make up a whole year so
this is a a process which has been in
place for years across this country just
trying to get a similar process in place
for kids of non-military parents
can i just have a follow up on that
so
so my question is
uh basically
uh
who does the military accept credit
accept credits or programs from is it is
it um
you said that they
public schools public academies approve
public or private tuition program
schools
and um as far as i understand
in in new hampshire uh we have we have
schools that are approved
that are for attendance only um and they
really don't have standards or approved
programs
um you know
and and we're also dealing with
competency based assessments so
um i'm wondering about the transfer
from that whether the military accepts
uh programs from
from those types of schools it seems
like the department of education and the
military uh is pretty strict about their
standards
and and
their education system is is very good
yes i'm aware it is not well i was in a
state which uh
at one point in time 50 percent of the
people living there were in the military
um and so we had a lot of transiency
amongst uh students uh many of the
students there attended public schools
within the community
that were approved by that state
department our fight
by the the local municipality in the
state in which they live so this
the standards which we have set up for
charter public schools public academies
approved public and private tuition
program schools
and agreements with vermont maine those
same
standards that we have for these
receiving schools
would i would imagine being required of
the school that's sending to these
schools and if they're not then that
gives pause for the principal to say i'm
not going to accept that course
okay thank you a representative jeff
question
yes mr chairman thank you uh
i'm getting a sense that we're drifting
a bit here because the military compact
refers to the children dependent
children of military service members as
they move from state to state local to
locale
not
not relating to the military and the
acceptance of credits for military
purposes that's correct
okay thank you
representative
yes thank you for taking that question
so
in our high
school we
students were able to take advantage of
extended learning opportunities from
plos
you could get credit on outside
experiences we would put together like a
little portfolio and it will be reviewed
by the school and you can get school
credit for that
is that
similar to what you're referring to
if it's approved by the administrator in
the facility that you're talking about
and they've gone through this match that
up with the standards that they require
for
for that particular course
thank you
see no other question follow up regular
delay
last minute
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking the question
uh
i'm new to the committee obviously so i
don't have the deep background everybody
else does but um
precisely what problem current problem
is this bill addressing because
everything i'm hearing is that i am not
hearing any evidence that there is any
problem
with the current system as it exists
so what problem is this addressing
well i can give you a personal
you know
a situation that i experienced with my
own kid
i moved from one state to another state
he took us
an accredited school in the state of
maine
in the city of rompers maine
when he moved to the district that i was
in and of course the accrediting
organization there was the northwest
association of schools and colleges
but because he took it as a freshman
and they offered it as he had another
level
uh and which was the sophomore and he
came in as a sophomore and didn't want
to have to take the us history course
again
they made him do so they would not
accept that credit that he had from the
ascending school which was for
basically when i looked at the syllabus
for both locations almost exactly the
same
but it wasn't in their their sequence in
which they taught
and they were basically looking to fill
some seats up in the classroom
thank you just a follow-up on that um
thank you for the the one personal
experience do you have any other wider
evidence of a problem
we do know that there's been situations
in this state where you think of course
you'd be
not been accepted by the receiving
school
and is that currently in the power of
the local district to make that decision
yes
and what does this change then this bill
it would give more thrust to saying why
was this course denied why was it from
the virtual learning academy that's
approved school in our state here
and you're you're now transferring to
community x why are you rejecting this
mr mr principal or does it mean
so the only change then would be that it
is simply asking the principal or
designee to offer an explanation
for the rejection that is the only
change being contemplated here
also got what the military has placed in
it similar courses and these similar
courses that vlax has they match the
standards which we have for this state
in certain subject areas uh i would
think that would cause themselves if it
were saying that's
there's not a justifiable reason for
rejecting that force
one final thing um
we seem to be referring constantly back
to the military compact but i have no
understanding of that
whatsoever and no familiarity with it
whatsoever and it strikes me that many
members of the committee do not should
we not then examine that military
compact and all the uh details and uh
possible um uh implications of that um
before we go ahead with this bill since
we seem to be relying upon that a great
deal thank you my answer to you is no
thank you for taking my question so uh
if
in this case um
somebody takes a vlax course
and the local principal
denies the credit for that particular
course
um
what's the what's the procedure
the the principal uh then or the the
person in charge maybe a superintendent
um
makes a reasonable justification who
who judy gate adjudicates
uh whether that is reasonable
and um
who makes the final decision on
this the principal made that final
decision
excuse me i didn't hear it i'm sorry
i'm saying that there is no course for
to get it adjudicated if the principal
makes that decision in that building
whether that course is going to be
accepted or not accepted
okay
i think right now
as a final final uh just a follow-up on
that so basically there's
it would just be the parents that could
then
take the
reasonable justification
um and pursue anything for that to to
say you know that you need to accept
this course
i i don't understand where we're going
with this um
basically what we're trying to establish
that if a horse is rejected by a
principle then they provide a reasonable
justification to the parent for that
denial
okay thank you
yes um
when thank you for taking my question i
think i remember last year when it came
up that there were places that were not
accepting velax
courses
we couldn't find an example of any place
that had said no
to velax and i don't know if that's
changed um
every place that we looked at did accept
the velax credits i i don't know of any
place that doesn't
is there a question in there
yes can can you give me examples of
places that don't accept velox credits
when we communicated with the department
of education department mentioned there
were some communities that have not they
did not give me the specific communities
and i'm not going to ask them to do that
that's something between the department
of education and those communities
thank you very much
thank
you we will uh move on to the
uh
next first news requested to testify
david dory
if you're all set
um
thank you was that uh was that me mr
chairman i had a little trouble
understanding yes it was
thank you
for uh taking my testimony good morning
to the
house education committee my name is
david dougherty i live in pembroke
and um
i did write a letter to the committee
about this bill um which i hope you all
received and i think that
explains my position on it um
unfortunately i
uh
did not have access to the amendment so
i can't really speak to that so i
apologize for that
but um
just uh
in terms of uh my objection i'll just
highlight some of my objections and and
go from there i think this bill um
represents um you know
legislative overreach and micromanaging
i think the system that's
in place right now works
uh schools um most schools as far as i
know all schools in the state of new
hampshire
try to give credit um
to students where credit is due
uh occasionally there might be
exceptions uh to that case and and
because of local circumstances
i think that um any decision by um
typically counselors
do the initial input on that and then it
may go to a principal and if
there's some question about it it can
always go up to the school board i think
there's a chain of command that
would take care of all the situations
um
i can't say i've ever had any experience
in terms of
military credits but i do know that um
i did deal with uh
velox when it was first initiated in the
state and always
accepted
credits for kids that was earned through
that institution
so i'll just wrap it up by saying that
i'd like to
encourage the committee to itl this bill
thank you for
listening to my testimony
thank you uh are there any questions
seeing none uh thank you very much
may i speak once again i'm sorry david
i'm sending you a screenshot of the
amendment
uh thank you and i think we have
one more uh person who wanted to testify
uh miss wilson of the school boards
association
i think i'm uh
right there
good morning can you hear me all right
great thank you mr chairman thank you
members of the committee my name is
becky wilson i am the director of
governmental relations for the new
hampshire school boards association i
did forward a copy of my written
testimony and many of the points have
already been covered so i'll try not to
take up too much of your time
and hsba is in opposition to house bill
182 as it's written
it does seem to not designate why
credits would be
looking to be granted the military
compact which is being referenced quite
often
obviously speaks to a very specific
situation where military families are
moving from district to district or
state to state this does not really
designate why a student would be looking
for
credits to be transferred from one
school to another if it's for residency
purposes families are moving that
certainly makes some sense
but i don't quite understand in the bill
we can't quite understand why
what other reason a student would be
seeking to add credit from some other
program um
the word programs is also still not
really defined in terms of whether or
not that applies to
just approved school programs or whether
there's other programs that students
might be seeking to transfer credits
from one to another
and reasonably justified for for denial
is also not defined i think that
most schools would if they are going to
deny a student to be able to transfer in
a credit would be looking to make sure
that they knew what would be a
considered a reasonable justification to
deny something like that
um and it just it's unclear what
situations this would really apply to it
does seem like an awfully broad bill for
what could be a pretty narrow or
specific situation that hasn't been
addressed through some other legislation
or other rsas that are already in place
and it does contradict
um rsa 189.1 roman numeral ii the school
board's authority over its own programs
and i think that's to the point that
some of the other uh people that have
spoken on this bill already today might
have already referenced um and i just
want to close by saying i agree that
most districts in new hampshire i don't
think
this is really an issue for students
when they move in
counselors are very attentive and put a
lot of time and care into transferring a
student from one district to another
district especially at the high school
level when there's so much at stake in
terms of credits there's a lot of
conversation that happens between school
districts to make sure that students are
meeting the right competencies that
they're placed in classes that are going
to cover competencies that maybe the
student hasn't already been exposed to
and not all courses cover the same
competencies from one district to
another so there's a lot of care that's
put into that process
and with that i'd just close and say i'm
happy to take any questions
thank you very much
any questions
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much ms wilson for uh for
joining us this morning so um beyond the
um the issue that you just brought up
with regards to
um competencies for you know a course in
one high school in new hampshire
not necessarily being the same as
competencies for a similar course
offered in a in another high school
aside from that um difference
do do you know do i guess do high
schools across the state
um have um do they all have the same
graduation requirements or or can they
have different graduation departments no
every local school board is responsible
for setting their own graduation
requirements in order to earn a school
district diploma from that particular
district there's obviously
core requirements that are required and
mandated across the state but many
schools offer different levels of
diplomas different types of diplomas a
different focus
in terms of that you can get an arts
diploma or new hampshire scholars
diploma there's many different
requirements for students across the
state so each district is responsible
for making sure that their program of
studies is going to allow students the
opportunity to earn their specific
diploma
so follow up on that mr chair
so so um thanks miss wilson um for for
that so so how would it work then where
a um a course taken at one high school
would have to be accepted
as a credit towards high school
graduation
by another
high school how would that even work
well to be perfectly honest i think for
the most part credits are awarded
towards graduation the place where
sometimes
there's some disagreement is in terms of
what requirement that credit may meet
and i think that's where sometimes this
conversation might fall down a bit
in looking at competencies from one
course and one school to competencies
for another course at a different school
they may fall under different graduation
requirements and sometimes
what's considered quote a core
competency or a core course at one high
school might be considered an elective
type credit at a different school so
it's not that the student wouldn't get
the credit it's just it may not be
applied in the same category or in the
same way to the new school
so the way that this particular bill
reads as well i mean i think there's a
good opportunity that you would have
students
unless they're moving again for
residency purposes you if it has nothing
to do with that you may have students
who are earning far more credits so to
speak in the elective categories but it
may not necessarily shorten or change
the student's
four-year plan for graduation
great thank you very much miss wilson um
see no other hands uh we will move on to
our next person to testify
uh that would be uh
carl from the new hampshire
thank you representative hobson by the
end of the session you'll get it
um
for the record my name is carl latt i'm
the executive director of the new
hampshire school administrators
association
um nhsaa is opposed to
this bill we haven't seen the
amended language so
obviously i'm going to be speaking from
the language that's been posted for the
public to um to read
though i certainly understand
representative ladd's intent
one of the things i would just like to
say
one of the differences
between the military families that are
moving
around and
students within our own state military
students may have very limited choices
based on their parent posting of what
kinds of educational opportunities are
available to them so it's both fair and
reasonable i think to provide more
latitude
in accepting credits this is a different
situation
although to some extent you could argue
that transients could be analogous
but i do have some questions about this
bill if
if this
denial by the principal is
there has to be a justification with
that if a justification is provided
would that then be appealable
to the state board of education
my sense is that
the state board of education would say
yes the local school board would
probably say no
and it should be public information
which schools do not accept velax
credits this is not this should not be a
mystery to anyone
i'm only aware of one school district
that had a policy
excluding velax credits
early on when vlax was first created
[Music]
and that's constantly being used to
justify learn everywhere
in this type of legislation and that
district has long since changed their
policy so that problem no longer exists
and so
my my sense is that what you're trying
to fix with this legislation has already
been fixed
principals and guidance counselors
already do the work outlined in this
bill no one wants to have students take
courses over if it's not necessary i
really think that this is a bill
and and with all due respect to
representative ladd there are a lot of
things that have changed in public
schools um
probably since your son transferred from
maine to alaska
so my guess is that you know we're
already doing this work uh this looks
like a bill that's uh in search of a
problem to fix when there is no problem
uh currently in this state
dealing with the acceptance of credits
so with that i'd i'd end my testimony
thank you very much
uh thank you dr
any questions
represent cornell
thank you for taking my questions so as
far as you know dr ladd there is no high
school in
new hampshire that does not accept relax
classes
to my knowledge there are none okay
thank you very much
all right see now
thank you mr chair and thank you um
dr ladd for taking my question it's it's
good to hear your voice um a question to
you is in relation to rule-making
authority
do you believe
that if this bill were to pass
that the department of education
could
in fact
impose
rules that would require
an overly harsh process that school
districts would have to follow
in order to make a denial in relation to
a particular course
thank you for the question
representative heath i i would imagine
that the department
would request such
a stance from the state board of
education and that they would enter into
rule making we saw that a couple of
years ago when a fairly innocuous bill
um
provided the opening for
the department of education to put
forward the learn everywhere program and
that to become part of rules when it was
not the intent of the original
legislation that enabled it so as much
as i certainly uh appreciate
representative ladd's
desire to
to to fix something
i just think that this could end up
being a much broader issue
than it currently is
thank you
thank you dr ladd i think we have one
more question to testify
um
yes hi
um good morning everyone thank you uh
chairman ladd and members of the
committee for the opportunity to speak
with you this morning um uh in
difference to time um respecting all of
your time and um as a result of the very
eloquent testimony offered this morning
by miss wilson and dr ladd i i don't
need to repeat many of the points you've
already heard
i think i would just like to echo
that
this appears to this specific
legislation uh almost appears to
undermine the current processes that
that exist
um really
a collaborative effort
of the review of transcripts is highly
collaborative uh exercise involving
multiple
staff members sending schools
with the
end goal of being that we're focused on
the students
and the quality of their experiences
and the learning outcomes that that we
aspire um for collectively um many
districts already have as dr carl stated
very clear policies that um
are very transparent for members of the
community to understand what's
transferable and and what is not
relative to um credits and
you know i i have grave concerns
about
our lack of definition of what
justification represents if a school
principle is to make the determination
that
denial of credits
is justified
it seems rather vague as to then what
next steps could be taken on behalf of a
party to overturn that decision and so
for for these reasons um we as an
organization oppose uh this bill and
again i i know i kind of cut in a little
late so bratty bellamere executive
director new hampshire association of
school principals
and i'm happy to take questions at this
time
thank you very much any questions
see none thank you
sure mr chair
so thanks very much and and thanks um ms
belinaire for uh joining us this morning
um
uh i was taking some notes while while
you were talking to apologize if if i
missed this but um but you know we've
had some conflicting testimony um so far
this morning with representative ladd
saying that the department of education
actually has a list of schools that um
do not accept uh velax credit and dr la
dr carlad uh indicating that um that
he's not aware of any school that um
that does not accept delac's credit and
i was just wondering if um
if if you can weigh in on one side or
the other on that um that conflict and
the evidence
certainly uh thank you for the question
representative luno um i i believe miss
wilson did um
allude to the fact that in rare
instances
um some
of velox credits may be considered
electives in some districts versus
competency-based transferable
and i think that is in my analysis and
in conversations with people in the
field
really the only issue that um that we
have heard and it's very rare so again
you know this is why i have concerns
that we're trying to address the
exception rather than the rule by
proposing this piece of legislation
okay thank you very much
uh see no further questions uh i thank
everybody and we'll close the hearing on
house bill 182
and i will turn the range back over here
thank you very much and with that we're
going to go ahead with our next bill
which is hb
276.
relative to availability of menstrual
hygiene products in schools
and with that i'd like to welcome the
sponsor of the bill represent edwards
is he there on the
sorry
so you represent aaron
[Music]
so
much
[Music]
um
probably what we can do because they're
not here we can see
is there anybody in the queue to
justify that waiting
for your pants
yeah i don't recognize
we're trying to find one of the sponsors
of the bill
yeah what we'll do is we'll take a five
minute break for those that need to take
a short break here and we'll come back
at 10 minutes after 11.
i'll excuse bosses let me back box out
right
about 11 10. yeah about 11 11 10 we'll
come back
actually it's 11 11 right
so we'll take a break and come back at
11 10 by our computer time
all right an hour later
yeah if i don't see anybody show up
that's responsive that we can put that
bill off and just jump in try to catch
up a little bit
represent vlad i'll just mute the room
until you guys are ready to get started
again
now i'm not hearing anybody
well because they're all immune when you
see these little
yeah
okay
thank you for coming together
thank you for coming to help
yeah
that's so awesome that's great didn't it
yeah i love it six degrees interesting
yes that's so awesome
the birds are going crazy around my
house
trying to find mates
and singing
what it's only 11.08 yeah okay oh well i
wanted to read the um
numbers from the last bill
just raise your voice about three
decimals higher than what you use
no no i mean when the time comes
you speak too softly
yeah
my kids don't think so
my husband doesn't think so my old
electronics says
oh really yeah
oh well uh the bill 276 medical
[Music]
uh
was representative hobson talking about
the um the blue sheet numbers for 182.
yeah she's going to give me that she's
just terrific thank you
okay it's 11 10
and what we're going to do is
we're about to get started we're going
ahead and starting right now
we're going to move past
276. but we're going to give you the
numbers on the 182 that i don't believe
that was uh addressed uh reps and hops
can you give the results of uh those
that supported everything
i think it is a monday i think we've
been fooled
so we had on hp 182 we had eight in
support
96 opposed
zero neutral and total testifying six
thank you okay i'm going to go ahead and
open up we will on hb 276 that will be
scheduled at a another time to be
announced
um
point of order mr chair
oh yeah yeah so so 276 is scheduled for
10 a.m today
and um and so we're obviously we're a
little over an hour
behind but i do believe there's probably
a lot of people that you know
took today off to testify
and um and also i think if you're going
to reschedule you at a minimum don't
don't you have to open up the hearing
and then recess to a time certain
i'm just going to reschedule to later to
this afternoon
jumping past to putting it there we've
done that earlier the he sponsors the
bill are not present
and
um
without uh a sponsor being present we're
going to
i will
put point of order though i mean um
in the in the in the past we've had um a
committee member
introduced the bill
and um uh you know and then and then you
know open it up for um
for testimony uh from others
and i believe we've got a lot of people
probably here that are
waiting to testify
uh on 276.
what i'm going to do is what i had done
earlier with another bill i will go
ahead and open it up and then i'm going
to immediately close it down and have it
continued later on this afternoon
after the last build
i'm going would you please i challenge
the ruling of the chair
on that
i just think that's eminently unfair
i think that disenfranchises members of
the public who have showed up today
taken time off from from their busy day
from work from school to to testify on
this and uh
um
you know people are watching
people representative
um
this will put off other people who are
waiting exactly
right how many people were signed up to
testify for this particular bill
six six people 1976 on 276.
[Music]
introduce the bill
so
in 276
i'll represent home would you please
introduce the bill
thank you mr
chairman i'd like to introduce house
bill 276
relative to availability of mental
hygiene products in schools
thank you very much
i will take no questions
okay with that
i'm going to
schedule the
input for 276 following the last bill
being heard today that'd be following hb
and move into i had challenged that that
decision so i'm going to challenge the
ruling of the chair
on that
yeah
um okay what i'm going to do is i'm
going to recess for 10 more minutes here
and open this thing up at 11 30.
jen can you turn this uh all right i'm
gonna ask dems to um to meet me in the
zoom caucus room but disconnect from
from this one first
i'll meet the room represent blood thank
you very much
[Music]
where you go there
okay
okay can everybody hear me
on
back to the issue of 276 i'm going to
have representative tordelli read a
statement or the rule that they just got
in from um
the house court
paul smith
go ahead thank you this is uh from the
clerk
um he is citing mason 626
paragraph
reads a special notice of a recess
committee meeting is not necessary if
the meeting involves the continuation of
the original meeting and assumes on the
same day
or before the passage of a specified
period of time
a challenge to the chair on recessing
the motion is not going to work
so what we are doing we are placing this
bill to follow the last bill
that we have scheduled today to file 198
this afternoon
when we upon
finishing that bill
so right now i'm going to
uh
and and
we have opened up uh 276 and we recessed
it until following 198.
point right now in hb 409 this is
relative to certain vacancies among
members of school boards and other
school district officers
so we i just promoted representative rum
welcome education how are you
so nice to see you representative hobson
thank you very much education committee
and chairman ladd
i come before you to introduce house
bill 409
this bill um
came to be because of a very tragic
death of a long-term
merrimack budget committee member mr
stanley heinrich
he has served our town over decades and
has contributed immensely to the quality
of life in merrimack
he died last year the day after filing
opened and there's nothing in statute
that directs our community on how to
fill that vacancy
in the past when this has happened we've
been
advised by the secretary of state's
office to
defer to the language that is in
in statute i'll bring it up it's it's
statute regarding vacancies within towns
so but there's nothing specific in the
statute
that governs school district
related
elections
so
what hb 409 does is it inserts the
identical language that we see
in
section 669 colon 61 pertaining to
vacancies that occurred during the
filing period
that exact language would be then
inserted into
671 colon 33 so that it will provide
guidance for school districts to be able
to
counsel the the their community on how
those vacancies are going to be filled
the specific language would um
anyone who if a vacancy occurs during
the that filing period it remains vacant
and until it's reappointed uh and then
the election is held at the following uh
election period
i hope i explain that clearly but i'll
be happy to take any of your questions
thank you thank you very much
representative are there any questions
for the representative
represent mullet
okay thank you very much mr chair for
recognizing me and thank you
representative rung for bringing this to
us today
um i just want to make sure because
i know you sent us that statute this
morning and i read it and i was no
clearer after i read it than i was
before i had it so
what you're saying is that if somebody
were to die during the filing period
then a person would be appointed to fill
that position
until
the next filing period when somebody
filed and ran for it and then a lot
could be
could be had
exactly um the situation that occurred
in merrimack is
since mr heinrich died the day after the
filing period open people wanted to file
for that position for the the upcoming
election
and what we're saying is that we're
we're going to follow the protocol
that's outlined in
uh
in towns related statute so that
that that that election for that vacancy
wouldn't happen until the following
election not the one
um that's determined for that filing
period
i don't know if i explained that
correctly there's a certain just a
follow-up to that
mr chairman um
so
so that but the but the vacancy that was
created by the person
being deceased
would be appointed
until that election the following year
right it
exactly it would be treated as if that
vacancy occurred after the filing period
closed not
[Music]
the end of available filing period in
the election but i'm really
a little bit baffled why if there's a
vacancy the final filing period is open
why prevent the town fault from uh
during a filing period from uh filing
for an open sea i i i could see
between the end but
i don't understand why
you would shut off people from
from uh filing when the filing period is
still open
well the thank you very much for your
question uh representative uh the intent
is to be consistent with the the
statutes governing uh the filling of
town
vacancies so um i think what what is
important is consistency between how we
feel vacancies on the town side and how
we fill vacancies on the school district
side
um i i think your proposal is is worth a
discussion but i think on the same point
it would then require a change in
section 669
we're really looking for consistency
this has been advice on the secretary of
state's office when this has happened on
the school side they just just follow
what you do for the town what we're
asking for well if we're going to follow
what we do for the town let's make sure
we put it in the statute that governs
school district elections
what's your name uh thank you
so representative so if somebody passed
away the day before the filing period
uh people could
file for that seat but if he passed away
or she passed away a day later at the
beginning of the filing period they
could not file for that is that is that
correct am i reading that correctly
yes that's consistent with what is in
669 governing town elections
we just want consistency between how we
elect people for town offices and how we
elect them for school district offices
thank you
thank you thank you for your questions
do you have a question
it was basically the same question
why would we not want people to file
if the filing period was still open
um
thank you very much for that question
represent like us i i mean it's a
worthwhile discussion but our point is
at this is to make consistency between
what's in statute for the town and
what's in statute for the school
district if if we want to say hey let's
let's fill vacancies that occur during
the filing period
i'm i'm open to having that discussion
but i think we need to have it on the
town side too i think it's very
confusing to voters and prospective
candidates when we have
one set of rules for how we govern
filling town
vacancies but then we lack any guidance
for filling those on the school district
side we just want some consistency
thank you thank you for your question
are there further questions of
representative rome yes uh yes griffin
bowman thank you mr chairman thank you
for the question thank you for taking
the questions
i'm sorry i didn't hear that question
there was a mic right over there
sorry there wasn't a microphone near me
now there is
okay i'm just looking and i'm looking at
like selectmen and it doesn't say
anything about this it says vacancy and
the board shall be filled by
appointments made by the remaining
selectmen and there's no reference at
all about
filing period and
so i'm trying to concern where
have you found that this makes it
consistent with other officers
yeah i mean if you'll see in
what i sent you this morning section 669
there is a sentence there that governs
how to fill a vacancy if it occurs
during the filing period
um
but that that does not exist in school
district in in in school district
vacancy language
could you give me the sub paragraph
because i'm looking look
i'll read it to you um
in 669 69 colon 6 1 roman numeral 3 i
think is where it is yes it says any
vacancy which occurs between the
beginning of the filing period and the
town election
shall not be filled by official ballot
until the annual town election the
following year
so that same sentence that's in 409 that
we want to put into the school district
statute
but i okay uh
further go ahead
so i think that
i could see that
in the law in both i can see that now
but doesn't that really refer to
if nobody has filed
um
no what it what it does it just extends
that vacancy until after the election so
it can be appointed and then and then
the person would you know candidates
would then run at the following
uh year the annual town election or
school district election the following
year you have another follow-up yes so
you're saying that this precludes
other people for running for that office
if somebody dies i mean
do you think that's right
um i i like i said i think it's worth to
have a discussion the intent of this
bill is just to
um
direct
school districts on how to fill those
vacancies that occur during a filing
period
and we want to make it consistent with
how we fill them at the at the town
level
now if we want to bring up uh another
subject about well let's
let's have people be able to file if
there is a vacancy that occurs during
the filing period i'm open for that
discussion but we need to do it on the
town side too not just the school
district
it's very difficult in a community where
we have one way of filling vacancies on
town side and another way of filling
them on the school district side and
actually we don't even have another way
of filling them on the school district
side because there's no language in the
statute that governs that
hb 409 intends to remedy that by having
language in statute to guide how we fill
those vacancies
and then you know if
if there's a discussion if there's
another bill filed to allow
um people to run for office during the
filing period
i'm open having that discussion but we
should make sure that it applies to both
town and school district thank you very
much representative
thank you representative
no no further questions for
representative we do have deputy
secretary uh dave scanlan ready
um perhaps that would be probably the
best way to
do
next
yeah unless there's another question for
representative
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee i'm david scanlon deputy
secretary of state and appearing today
in support of the bill that
representative wrong has sponsored
because it does clarify the statute
along the lines of the advice that we
would give to school districts if a
vacancy occurred
in this manner
you know i understand that there is a
question is why do we close it off at
the first day of the filing period in
terms of being able to put somebody on
the ballot there's a couple of reasons
for that the first one is administrative
and
it there's a process by which
constituents citizens in a community
are aware of offices that are up for
election
and they can make a determination ahead
of time plan on running for the office
and sign up and and get their name on
the ballot
when a vacancy occurs during the filing
period
there is at that point no time to
advertise that that they that that
there's a potential opening on the
ballot
to run for an office and so it it
precludes you know the full spectrum of
potential candidates from
being able to participate
the second
aspect of this is
is
not creating an opportunity for games to
be played on who might get on the ballot
a vacancy occurs for other reasons
besides somebody just passing away
it can be cut it can because uh somebody
moves out of town
and is no longer qualified to be on the
ballot or it can simply be somebody's
resigns
they submit a letter of resignation um
you know if that is done on the last day
of the filing period and conveniently
there's somebody else to step up and say
i'm going to run for that office and
sign up
uh that's hardly fair either and
so that's the reason why the policy is
the way it is it's why the
uh statute for town elections
uh specifically states this is the way
the process would be
and uh and we believe it that it's the
right process
so again we support representative runs
legislation and i would be happy to
answer any questions
thank you very much mr scanlon uh
representative moffat do you have a
question i used to do it thank you thank
you
very much uh thank you mr deputy
secretary uh
uh staggered positions uh
so my question for you is
is
uh is that different than someone who
dies who is not
making
um
well if if somebody is up for
re-election
um
and
so there would be an open filing period
because that that office is on the
ballot if a candidate dies um or passes
away
after they have filed or um
uh or you know
sometime before between the filing
period and the election
um that person's name would simply be
removed from the ballot at that point uh
because of the of the death or the
uh or the uh
resignation and then i for town and
school district elections
uh there is no other opportunity for
somebody else to step forward and run
for that office because these offices
are nonpartisan it's you know anybody
can run
the situation that we are talking about
with this legislation is
in the case of
uh
a an office holder whose position is not
up for election
uh and that office then becomes vacant
um
uh
and and the standard practice is no
matter when when it happens during the
course of a year and say after the
election's over
you know we're into the month of august
and
and then there's a vacancy that occurs
the standard practice is that the
appointing authority
um
it could be the school board in this
case could be the board of selectmen it
could be the planning board or the
zoning board depending on what office
you're talking about get to make the
appointment
until the next election and then an
election would be held to fill the
unexpired term of that particular office
what what this language is doing is just
it just talks about
uh what happens in you know when you get
close to the proximity where people are
actually signing up to run for office
for the next election and
um the the the policy has been and the
statute in the case of towns has been
that that there is a clear delineation
of
of you know if there is a vacancy
whether an appointment is made versus
when uh somebody is able to get their
name on the ballot and run for that uh
that position
yes follow up uh
thank you mr chair so what i'm hearing
uh mr deputy secretary is uh to my
earlier question if it's a position
that's not scheduled for reelection i
think i understand that that
would
the statute would cover that like if
representative
school board member smith is a is up for
re-election and i have been planning to
run against school school board member
smith and he dies the first day of
filing
when i was going to file to run for
receipt would this preclude me from
running for uh school board for a seat
that i've been playing to run for that
was open
no because if the seat is up for
election there's a filing period that's
taking place for that seat and so if the
incumbent
who is also running for the office
passes away
during that filing period
at that point it does not preclude
anybody else from stepping forward and
signing up
because the filing period is open
specifically for that office
what we're talking about in this in this
piece of legislation is a bill
uh is for a position
that would not be up for
its its normal election cycle it would
be mid-term i'll call it and um
if let's say if the if the person
holding the office still has two years
left in the term and they die a vacancy
exists that office would not normally be
on the ballot
uh if the person created the vacancy
prior to the filing period there would
be an opportunity to put it on the
ballot for the remaining balance of the
term whatever that might be
um but
this this language is dealing
specifically with a position that would
not otherwise be up for election
thank you that interests my question
thank you very much representative you
have a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question so i just want to
clarify here
so if i'm on a school board and i resign
the day before the filing period
that office is open for election
but if i resign
once the filing period opens the day the
filing period opens that office is not
open for the next election and is uh my
vacancy would be filled by appointment
am i correct on that you are correct
what is the logic behind that one day
difference
uh
i think that's that's a good question
except i think so too
except that you know the filing period
has has opened up at that point and
and there was no uh there was no prior
advertisement for the position and
granted in the scenario that you just
described there would be little
opportunity to advertise
you know that position as well i mean i
understand
the situation but in this case it's just
a it's a line that's drawn
uh in the sand
thank you thank you
uh are there further questions for the
secretary of state's office
thank you very much mr scanlan my
pleasure thank you
all right uh
who's next here
next we have um
welcome to education she is
any years back
yes i can hear you can you hear me
excellent
i'm the merrimack school district clerk
and i've been the clerk for 25 years
and i've been sitting here because i
knew the answers to most many of the
questions um i asked representative rung
to put this forward
because when my husband died during the
filing period
um
well let me start this by saying
when other members of the
school board or the school budget
committee or the school planning
committee would talk to me about i'm
thinking of resigning i would tell them
always resign before filing period so i
can advertise the position properly
or wait until after the election and
then let the board that you're on deal
with the vacancy
um
unfortunately in this case and my
husband died after the filing period
opened
i called the superintendent i called the
secretary of state's office and was told
that there is nothing in
but they suggest to school districts and
school district clerks that they follow
669.
they also suggest that i contact our
school council which i did and the
school uh legal counsel told me to
follow 669.
um
i found myself thinking this has
happened before and let's prevent it
from happening again
if it's good enough for the town it
should be good enough for the schools
and i'd like to see that language
inserted in 671 to cover this
i had people come up to me
the day before my husband's funeral to
tell me
that the budget committee could tell me
i had to put it on the ballot
uh i had people tell me that the
secretary of state's office suggested
there was a gray area
and this could be put on the ballot
but just like people that file for
office you have to be registered to vote
before the filing period opens
and
the seat has to be vacant before the
filing period opens
i agree with that and i would like to
see that i'm asking you to please put
that in
because we do have people that have
resigned that not just die but resign
and it would be nice our the town filing
period is the same as the school
district filing period
and since there's something in the
town's election law that says the
vacancy will be filled according to the
body if a vacancy occurs during the
filing period
um i'd like to have the town and the
school be the same
rather than have the town do it one way
and the school do it another way
and in my husband's case in particular
originally we had a municipal budget
committee
and until we had a town charter that
eliminated the municipal budget
committee in his case he has an elected
seat on the school planning board and he
had an elected seat on it at that time
the municipal budget committee
and we could be looking at a case where
the town didn't put the budget committee
seat on the town ballot and
what's the school supposed to do
for the same person's death
people do resign
but hopefully they contact me ahead of
time so that i can have them file before
that i can have them resign before the
filing period opens so that i can
advertise the seat because in merrimack
we do advertise the filing period and
what positions are open
so thank you for listening to me
are there questions for the presenter
thank you
uh steve next we have
um school board association
welcome to education
thank you very much representative
hobson thank you very much chairman ladd
members of the committee bear christina
from the new hampshire school board
association
um we were initially opposed to house
bill 409 and we're gonna keep that
opposition on the record but um hearing
representative rung um and and the other
speakers uh state why they think this is
um a good bill uh
and and representative rung did say a
couple times that she thinks it was
worth the conversation um we think
retaining this would probably be
appropriate so we can um sort through
the myriad of statutes in rsa 671 and
rsa 669.
the other statute that i would like to
um point you to just in case there would
be a conflict between house bill 409 is
rsa 197 colon 26.
um this says uh the school board shall
fill vacancies occurring on the board
and in other districts except that a
moderator until the next annual meeting
of the district
the shell means that they have to and
that they have to fill the vacancy so i
just not sure how filling that vacancy
um to the next annual meeting would
would play into
um playing into the election um aspect
that this is this is trying to address
um
representative moffat we had some the
same questions um that you had um and
one aspect i would um
like to to point out with respect to
attorney scanlon's testimony i believe
he wrote this is for a seat that is in
mid-term it's not for an open seat
because there seems to be a lot of
questions about well i was planning on
running it anyway um if that's the case
i don't think the language of the bills
clearly
states that i think this occurs to all
vacancies that occur within that filing
period window i don't think that as
written it would only occur to sort of
mid
term
vacancies
so um those were some of the concerns
that nhsba had with the bill
um again we appreciate representative
rung for for bringing this up um and and
indeed having the conversation uh there
are a lot of areas where school
districts have to borrow from rsa 669
because rsa 671 is not specifically
clear
but apparently this is another one of
those issues but again we have some
concerns about the perhaps unintended
consequences how this may relate to rsa
197 colon 26 as i mentioned and i think
language needs to be if the intent is
that this is only to apply to to
mid-term seats um then i think that
needs to be made more explicit within
the bill so while we do oppose the bill
um we think that um retaining the bill
maybe working on some language over the
summer or the fall might be appropriate
and with that um uh conclude my
testimony i'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much uh mr
christina are there questions for the
national school boards association
not seen
thank you very much
thank you very much mr chair
yeah
we have one other dog
[Music]
she must be
okay so
we have any other
books no
so with that can you please give us a
reading on
how things were signed up
uh yes
representative hobson can you somehow
get a microphone closer to you because
it's almost impossible to hear what
you're saying and that may be the
problem that people who are supposed to
be speaking have no idea that you're
calling on them can you hear me now
yes
um okay so
valerie vallant
uh are you
able to speak did you not hear me before
[Music]
okay sorry and uh
rep lei you've had your hand up as well
yeah i just had a i was just wondering
if uh uh mr scanlon is still available
uh or if we could just send him a
question um i was just wondering what
happens if somebody it's if if it is
restricted to just those
um seats that are up for election and
let's say i'm running
uh for re-election and i suddenly pass
away
um during the filing period but someone
has already filed to run against me is
that person now barred to run
he's no longer uh attending
so yeah yeah see i think there are just
sort of
different permutations that haven't been
right i agree okay sorry i'll ask later
uh representative
from in my notes
uh he said
that it's
only an unexpired term so you wouldn't
be
up for
elections so it wouldn't apply to you
in in the statement you just uh
the question you just have so it's just
for vacancies where the seat is not up
for election
okay thank you
are there further
concerns okay uh what was the final
count there
so final count i have three at support
six oppose
zero neutral and total testifying would
be three
four does that four test five is four
four four
we are oh
uh this testimony our this hearing on hp
409.
uh
how many people we have signed up for hp
we have three people signed up to
testify three people yeah
okay i'm gonna try to get that in so we
can take our break then at 12 30.
um so with that i am going to open up hb
this is relevant to the apportionment of
costs in cooperative school districts
okay representative mcgee is the
singular
sponsor on that bill
let's see
welcome to education
thank you so much it's great to be with
you again uh thank you chairman ladd and
vice chairman cordelie
and members of health education i'm here
today to represent my town and my town
school moderators
on an issue that's come up in our town
before which is on
apportionment language in
rsa 195 colon 8 so i have written
testimony so i can keep within my time
frame and then i'm happy to take
questions
um i'm representative cat mcgee of
hillsborough 27 hollis
and i as i mentioned i'm coming to you
today on hb 152 on behalf of my town
and the moderators therein who uncovered
a problem in the statute that they
thought could easily be solved
so the bill proposes a small change to
rsa 195 colon 8
which already calls for apportionment
calculations to be revisited every five
years
and no sooner
um so
the trigger for five years
will no longer be merely based on a
formula change
but also if an article a warrant article
to continue the current formula has been
passed at the district meeting
so the idea is right now the language
um promotes the fact that a change has
to be um reached
and in several of the meetings i've been
to recently there's you know with when
the five-year anniversary is up there'll
be a vote for a dollar change or
whatever because they don't really want
to revisit that
for anyone who
is in um
a a portion a district co-op
they understand that
those negotiations can be very
contentious a lot of money goes back and
forth depending on changes to the
formula
and so from the moderators perspective
this change would make
the process of being able to allow the
governing body to have a vote on whether
they're happy with the formula without
making a change
and then they would be able to continue
for five years from that
folks had posited questions of the
moderator when he first proposed this
change as to well what if that vote
fails and if it fails then you just stay
on the same calendar that you're on for
revisiting apportionment
um so
i i i didn't read what i have here
because that's basically it in a
nutshell
and so um i also wanted to mention to
you that our long-time moderator and
most experienced moderator in town is
the honorable jim bellander who was the
former chair of municipal county and
government and he is on the line
although he is moderating our elections
today because it's town election day um
as is the current um moderator for the
town drew mason who's the person who
first proposed this bill to me
so um
see if there's anything else
i can tell you from here
um
so
yeah i i think i think i've probably
given you enough to get you started and
i'm sure you'll have questions so
um and there's jim as well so both of us
would be happy to answer any questions
that you have but if you look
at um at the bolded language in 152
that's probably in front of you
it's just adding language that says
if the apportionment formula for a
cooperative school district has been
duly changed
and it adds or if an article to continue
the current formula has been passed at
the district meeting so that's all we're
trying to do is just add language that
supports the idea that the body can
decide not to make a change and also
agree that the formula is sufficient for
another five years
so i hope that makes sense
are there any questions for the
representative
not seen in hands thank you very much
thank you
next we have uh the honorable
jim belanger i've promoted him uh
welcome to education
well thank you very much uh for uh
welcoming me i thought i got uh shut off
there for a second because the whole
thing disappeared and then came back
just when representative mcgee was
paying me compliments
i'm jim belanger of hollis new hampshire
and are representing myself
and mr drew mason the current moderator
of the hollis brookline cooperative
school district
who is also the town moderator and is
busy at the polls today as you can
imagine
i'm a former new hampshire state rep
serving on the municipal county
government committee for nine years
and if you add my years of being a
moderator in town for town school and
cooperative school district i have 40
years of experience this bill makes
sense
house bill 152 concerns an issue which
simply provides a fix
for a loophole in current legislation
right now the apportionment formula for
a cooperative school district is subject
to be reviewed every five years
most have no objection to this if after
review the formula is changed and then
it can be reviewed again in five years
however the way current law is worded if
the formula is reviewed and found to be
satisfactory
it can be reviewed again the next year
and the next year and the next year
isn't reviewing and deciding to leave it
alone a decision that should also have a
five-year term
what if the formula is changed by one
penny
i ask you to recognize that taking up an
article debating it and deciding to
leave it as is
meets the intent of the current rsas and
should be considered the same as if one
penny had been added to the formula
the voters took it up
spoke about it and decided it was good
as is and that should suffice for the
next five years
now that's my input and because
moderator drew mason could not be here i
would like to read his comments
i am the moderator of the hollis
brookline cooperative school district i
would like to thank representative mcgee
for filing this bill and for working
with me through the process
i believe this bill is a small but
important improvement to the rsas about
apportionment
as i'm sure you know the costs of
cooperative school districts are divided
among the participating towns
by an abortion formula
under current law once adopted the
formula can be reviewed after five years
but no sooner
if the voters in the cooperative school
district change the formula the new
formula is enforced for at least another
five years
the key word in that statement is change
in order to enter a new five-year period
of formula stability the voters must
change the formula
the requirement of the change and the
formula has come up the last two times
that my district has voted on
apportionment
this bill allows the voters to continue
using the current formula and have
another five years of predictable
apportionment if they so choose in order
to keep the existing formula a majority
of the voters in the cooperative
district have to vote in favor of it
the apportionment formula is about as
basic and direct as a
pocketbook issue as there can be
with a single vote millions of dollars
in taxes can be shifted among downs
up with the suitable apportionment
formula requires careful research
thought and all
compromise
it can be quite contentious restricting
the frequency of review
of the formula allows the voters school
board and budget committee to focus on
other things
the legislators who created the concept
of a cooperative school district had the
foresight to provide for a five-year gap
between formula reviews this is a very
good thing
this bill says that if voters choose to
continue with the existing formula
or choose to change the formula they can
enjoy another five years with
predictable formula when i explain this
bill to folks they ask what happens if
the bill apportionment article is
defeated
the answer is exactly the same as
current law the then current formula
continues to be used and the voters may
take up apportionment at the next annual
meeting
the five-year period does not start
regardless of the nature of the defeated
article
i know this phrase has been a bit
overused but with this bill if you like
your apportionment formula you may keep
it without going through the contentious
process
required by the current law
finally when hollis brookline went
through a reapportionment and the school
board wanted to keep the existing
formula because of current law the
school board had to propose the exact
same formula then modify it to add one
dollar to hollis share
then explain to the voters why
i think it seemed a little silly to the
voters but they did approve it quite
handily 469
to 180.
that concludes my
testimony on behalf of myself and
moderator mason thank you
thank you very much jim are there any
questions for mr belanger
now seeing hands thank you very much and
have fun at the polls
well thank you very much rick and thanks
for not calling me honorable jim
[Music]
no
thank you again everyone thank you
chairman members of the committee i'll
be very brief uh nhsba supports um house
bill 152
uh we uh appreciate uh representative
mcgee and uh former representative
belanger for their cogent statements on
this i just wanted to give you a little
bit of a background because um nhsba was
contacted it's my understanding about
maybe three four maybe five years ago
there was a petitioned warrant article
in house brookline to change the
apportionment formula between the the
two towns for the cooperative school
district
at the annual meeting that petitioned
warrant article was amended to basically
keep the status quo
apportionment formula between the two
towns
that status quo amendment or the
amendment to keep the status quo passed
so the question was is that a change
because we the voters took some
affirmative action on this warrant
article so even though in reality it was
still remaining the same the question
was whether or not that vote at the
annual meeting constituted a change for
that five-year period um so um i i
when i got that question i said that's a
good question i don't have an answer to
that so anyway um we think that um
we think that this is good practice even
if the apportionment formula does not
change if the voters vote to keep the
same apportionment formula
having that five-year window in between
bringing it back is is good for budget
committees good for school boards to be
able to budget and for people to have
some um uh semblance of understanding of
what their their fiscal impact is going
to be so they can plan appropriately so
with that uh we certainly support um
house bill 152 and i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you very much
are there any questions for the school
boys association
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you very much
mr chair that was our last speaker on
this bill okay uh do you have the number
of people that you know
signed up i do i have uh five in support
three opposed zero neutral and
testifying three thank you very much
so with that we're going to close this
hearing um
our excuse me
152 is closed and we are going to break
for lunch and come back at one o'clock
please
thank you
why is that on all of a sudden
no no
no
is it yours
it's your
are you muted on that thing
let's see
see i changed screens no no i'm i've got
no
sound in here
here
pretty
you
okay
foreign
hmm
uh
fifth
[Music]
yes we are
wearing these glasses and your mask at
the same time yes
don't want to stay on
time
[Music]
oh
uh
okay can you hear us oh thank you
okay i'm seeing some heads coming out of
these yes okay so i'd like to go ahead
and continue with our hearings right now
we have a hearing schedule for one
o'clock here hb 464 relative to the
commission to study school funding
464 and i'd like to uh welcome
representatives
uh thank you very much mr chairman
uh director
cornelling for exactly
sandwich and the beautiful engine
and uh
this is a very
simple bill
uh asked we are all aware uh legislation
in the last participants established a
school funding commission
with a budget
of uh half a million dollars
and that
commission
has issued their report in december
and uh i think that uh the work is done
and that the
commission
would be uh
remaining funds that were allocated for
the purpose of the commission shouldn't
return to the education trust fund
and it's uh that simple their work is
done and uh we should
move on with whatever action
school plumbing is going to be taking
in this binding
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you very much representative
are there questions from benjamin i
prefer not to take questions um the
difference to the time and catching up
okay uh
conversation who do we have next we have
uh
welcome back to education mr dr ladd
from the new hampshire school
administrators association
thank you representative hobson for the
record my name is carl lab
executive director of the new hampshire
school administrators association
i understand that representative
cordelli thinks that the the work of the
commission is completed
but i don't believe that that is
necessarily true
there is still
an outstanding question about what's
happening with
education funding in our state
and the commission's work
remains relevant and important to the
field
until some some of those questions are
resolved
by the legislature
which they have not been as of yet so i
would i would urge
you to
vote this bill itl
and let the commission continue its work
thank you
thank you very much dr ladd are there
questions for the school administrators
association
i see none thank you very much
um
uh that
if you can believe it is the
oh
welcome to education
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much president hobson um i just
want to very briefly uh
just say basically the same thing that a
doctor led just said that the
commission's work is not finished and we
should uh continue its work i'm
not sure exactly how significant the
funds are but we in the legislature
we're not in having to spend our own
money on things and this is a very uh
this report obviously
um leveraged a lot of a lot of resources
that we didn't pay for and that's
probably somebody else is paying for
like um
one this first came to my attention you
talked about the uh
the permanent commission the study and
um
and they referred to report which was
what has been issued by january 10 2021
and usually
nobody can tell if those reports have
been filed i have no idea where to find
most of them this one actually
was finished early in the december 1st
2020 um actually only
only three months
only three months after the original
deadline which was september 1st so even
with the pandemic and everything
happened the committee
met many many times presumably by zoom i
believe it was by zoom and uh
and they did get a use of resources as i
said of many other agencies apparently
the carson school of unh like this
report
unlike any unlike just about the any
other study committee you can actually
find a report online without any trouble
you just
just takes a very minimal amount of
googling um also the agendas of all the
meetings and all the documents submitted
all that stuff is online which is
usually not the case for study committee
usually
you know there's that
this bill at the boy
there's a boilerplate language at the
end of rsa193 and how they're fighting
with the senate clerk house clerk and
state library and um
i tried to just for last i decided to
log on to the state library to see like
where all the other study committee
reports are they're probably in their
physical form somewhere in the library
if i wanted to
slip over to concord and risk catching
covet and all that but
they're not online except well except a
very few of them maybe are collected by
somebody else and donate to the library
so this is a
very nice study committee it's uh
but whoever however this is funded
there's obviously a lot more funding
than the study committees usually get
and uh
i applaud the chair who's
of current event education revenue luna
and the many other people who worked on
the report and um
[Music]
so i i think i think the commission's
work is not finished the general court
has not addressed the recommendations um
i have no idea when they're going to
recommend them um i'm not exactly
i'm not necessarily optimistic that
we'll pass a
a budgeted bill by the deadline i think
we're going to attend a resolution so
the minimum uh you know
and even if we
do do that in time that's uh
that's um
that's not till uh june 30th and i think
the
work will continue for more than 60 days
after june 30th they have a notice on
their website which once again you can
see even the future meetings when it's
hard to find out but they have a couple
of zoom forums scheduled uh
tomorrow and a couple weeks from now and
they have a variety of other activities
and um
so i think uh
so i think i think we should keep keep
the law the way it is we should keep the
committee commission keep whatever
funding it has which i can't imagine
it's a huge amount um and it continues
work and i might also add
i know when i saw the bill the original
bill 2019 then revised in 2020 i did
wonder like uh
what about the broad-based sales and
income tax but uh that was
not specifically included by the
committee's charge but it uh wasn't
mentioned either they did specifically
mention the properties act and they did
uh
they did respect political reality that
anything involves a broad base you know
that avoiding a broad-based sales or
income taxes much higher prices and even
higher priority than educating our
students so um
so they they respected that and they i
mean in all fairness so they did suggest
some fundamental changes in how the
property taxes in our state are of
course been collected and that that
could be a problem but still they
they did it within the uh
boundaries this legislator has set
itself for uh for decades i think even
since my
even since back when my father served in
the late 1970s so i thank the committee
for its work i think this bill is
unnecessary and frankly a little bit of
an insult to all the hard work that was
put into it so i would um
i would urge you to uh
let the commission continue until we
actually address that problem and
hopefully uh hopefully we'll address it
at least partially why whenever we can
pass a budget so that's uh
that's what i had to say so
um thank you very much
i mean i could take questions but i
think you probably uh
want to move on the other items on your
agenda so thank you
thank you very much representative
questions for representative
representative
uh thank you mr chair and thank you
representative horgan for taking my
question uh you've been in the
legislature a long time longer than i
have and i was just wondering uh is this
a common thing that happens is this
something that uh you know that people
put through bills to stop a commission
um like
cut it off at the
at the end like this
well not i know i'm speaking only as one
member of the uh
one member of the minority caucus i'm
not speaking even for them or anybody
but myself but i i i don't recall ever
seeing this um that seems like a
pretty unusual situation especially
this is a kitty that was taken more
seriously than a lot of them the only
one that i remember being taken that
seriously was one about the uh
was one about the death penalty that we
had uh i don't know
sometime around 2000 i think lee was
during my first term so and
well this is a good or bad thing but it
uh
took us
several more sessions before we actually
addressed that issue so you know this is
like pretty unusual like cutting off
study committee before its work is done
even though
even the report has been filed and as i
said it's unusual to actually be able to
find it that easily on fine and
it was actually filed ahead of deadline
but yes
i think this is unusual
thank you
thank you very much uh representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative oregon for taking my
question
uh there are those who feel that the the
commission its report are inherently
flawed and compromised due to the
perception that
the commission's composition included
pretty much like-minded established
education establishment folks who
had similar uh world views for example
five of the six
legislators in the commission of the
same party so the question is those
concerns have any validity in your
uh
well i think
as far as i know the individuals on the
committee the legislative members are
all very fair-minded people um even
though some of them had
even though there wasn't necessarily
even a number of d's and arts so i'm not
a i
i certainly have immense amount of
respect for all the individuals on the
committee and all the rest of the hard
work so i mean this uh
you know
the study commission is just a view of
the people who worked on this
this is an issue that we're never going
to solve completely but i i i think it's
i think i think i think it's a good
report and you can either uh you can
choose to
you can we can we're all free to uh you
know implement the parts that we think
we're like and to not implement the
parts we don't agree with so that's uh
not really
no study committee is ever gonna if it
does
if it doesn't work it's gonna put out a
report that everyone's gonna agree with
and they also the final document that
was issued
over a month ahead of schedule on
december 1st uh 2020 does include about
25 pages of uh you know sort of
dissenting reports from from uh from the
activity members
that's about all i have to say about
that i'm not necessarily saying
everything is correct
and none of it's correct but
i still think uh don't think i'm just
saying i'm just supporting continuing
continuing the effort for at least a
little
at least which would probably be at
least for the rest of the year so thanks
representative thompson do you have a
question yes thank you mr chair and um
thank you rap morgan for taking my
question
um
i was wondering if the committee has
already issued a report
uh with their findings what work is left
to be done
well um
i don't know if i'm not the person i was
not on the committee i actually
i think i zoomed in to only a handful of
meetings briefly but um well it says uh
the work is continuing and it's
apparently leveraging as i said outside
funding this is certainly
a lot
this is a lot more extensive and a lot
more technological you know a lot more
sophisticated than what
a regular study committees do so they do
have like some community forums and
other activities and also just
specifically says um
you know
the final report is not quite the end of
the process so in this case uh the
commission has activities scheduled for
after that which is um
until and when the general court
addresses his recommendations and um
obviously they'll never be addressed to
everyone's satisfaction but presumably
when and if we ever pass a budget
trailer bill and i'm i'm personally
pessimistic given that we didn't even
see the first draft of the budget bill
until like
that's the uh march 2nd i think so even
that's all we're already three weeks
behind schedule in that process but
i'm sure it will be addressed in some
way by the time we actually pass some uh
it doesn't pass the budget so that's um
and then so that
probably takes us pretty far into this
year but i think you know
cutting it off too much too much for now
like as or as of whenever we pass it
which might be early as we can pass this
is march 31st i'm getting off into the
weed here of course but like i think uh
you know terminated on march terminate
this on march 31st i think it's just
massively premature so that's just my
opinion so i'm really i'm not the expert
on the work of the community that others
can discuss that amongst yourselves
since there were some members of the
committee on the standing committee here
that
probably shouldn't have taken questions
from but i guess i'll take some more if
anybody
thank you
thank you very much for representing
oregon are there further questions for
representative oregon
martin thank you very much well thank
you
yeah
i don't see anyone else scheduled to
testify nobody's got their hand raised
um mr chair
yes represent
yes just a question of the chair
on um on house bill 464 and i just want
to um take a look at it while i'm
asking the the question but um but where
the where the um the statues is amended
um
my understanding is um
that would not affect uh
things like what representative horrigan
was talking about which is maintenance
of the commission's website
which under contract is to be maintained
for five years by the kharsi school at
unh
due to the collection of materials that
was there and the investment made by the
state of new hampshire so i was just
wondering if you could confirm that
yes i will um that
that that was not part of
that's not how it's been done
the commission report is a commission
report just like any other commission
report we've had set up by this
legislature um currently it's uh being
handled through rc seeing that we that
has been part of the support system
which that commission had
and using for that half a million
dollars for it
so uh everything
is being handled in accordance with the
way the program is set up and i have no
problem with that uh representative
great thank you
are they ready for the numbers
yes go ahead please
um
so we have eight
in support
29 opposed
zero neutral and two tests
okay did everybody get those numbers
eight twenty nine zero and two
so with that i'm going to close the
hearing for hd 464.
um
and the next uh hearing is scheduled to
start at
1 30.
so we have a few moments
wait
i do not plan on the second bills today
just so
all can understand that yes
so that may help some make their plans i
don't want people
and having to worry about that
cornell house
represent cornell i'd like to make a
motion or a request whatever it should
be called um
when we were talking about the amendment
to 182 there seemed to be
different answers to whether velax is
accepted or not
and i'd like to ask the department of
education for the list of um schools who
actually have
rejected velax
classes
um before we execute this i i would
you know dr ladd and bridie bellamy are
the principals and the um
the superintendents associations are
saying that
in their recognition
recollection
there really aren't any that are
rejected but then we hear numerous times
in testimony that the department of ed
says that
velax is rejected from schools so i
would like to know you know where the
department of ed is getting that
information which schools are rejecting
and how many there are
represent cornell you may ask them
nobody's preventing you from doing that
okay
thank you
okay so we have a few moments here
um
the other thing i'd like to briefly
discuss is that we do have a
subcommittee that's uh scheduled to meet
at 10 o'clock
on um
this friday
to look at the post-secondary merger um
this is
in my way of looking at where we are in
education a very very important issue
um how we uh manage our academic and
financial affairs and addressing
post-secondary education is extremely
important
um
if anybody here has not had an
opportunity to look at hb2
and to look at the language within hb2
which addresses this i encourage you to
do that
um the committee is scheduled
uh
and at this point i have not changed any
of the times i know i've heard from
several people that
are in merrimack county and there's a
conflict with the 10 o'clock meeting
with the county delegation on that same
day that was unknown when we went and
scheduled it i also have dr ed mckay
scheduled to speak already at techwalk
on friday morning
and um
dr mckay is a fountain of information
and i i encourage um anybody that's in
this committee's welcome welcome to
listen and and and
as we do in many of our subcommittee
meetings
where we have uh
participants assigned and uh it's not a
closed situation at all
um we've had several reports which have
been uh provided to us uh one by several
reports by oliver ford who was past
president of the university of
massachusetts lowell and went through
this with little technical institute uh
and doing some merging there
i've read a report that deals with uh
mergers in several other states
connecticut minnesota alaska i'm very
familiar with the merger in alaska which
created huge problems
uh although alaska is a very different
state and has many different cultural
aspects and geographic
distances are something that can't be
compared to new hampshire they should be
compared to the entire country
so by reading that they come up with and
they the report's been written by
notable new england associations
there are
10 or so real concerns
elements that must be addressed and so
what we will be doing as a committee
on that first meeting this coming friday
he's working with ted
trying to identify these broad
broad themes
which need to be conveyed to the finance
people when they're looking at this
issue of merger
whether it can be achieved in one year
two year three years um what are the
ramifications
the consequences that really are not
known about at this point in time have
been properly dealt with before we've
done that giant leap
because this will uh
tear apart the press and structure we
have for how we run our post-secondary
institutions the
trustees of the community college system
at the university system will be done
away with and there'll be a new
overarching trustee board of 15 people
um
and uh that is of that one third will be
appointed by the governor the other two
thirds uh from the
institutions no
so um i encourage folks if you have a
moment to tune in if you don't have a
copy of the
zoom link for that i'm asking now that
jennifer who's listening that we would
also ensure that that link is provided
to all education committee members so
you can hop online and and listen
and
observe where we're going
once again this is a real important
issue unfortunately we don't have the
time to make this a real proper study
we're going to just come up with some
overarching
uh facts
knowledge that we can find and provide
that fiscal finance committee
and with they can
take and run with that information
so i see a hand up there is that you
mary
yes it is i'm sorry mr chair um we come
division two of finance we're also
meeting um with the university system
and the community college is that the
same meeting or are these two separate
meetings i believe there are two
separate meetings uh i've been asked by
uh karen humberger
to help provide this policy information
i'm figuring it's best that it comes
from policy people
here
and we have some knowledgeable people on
this committee that have backgrounds
in this arena so i think we can offer
something to them even though we don't
have that much time
thank you very much
um mr chair
yes
so so i think what what representative
heath was just highlighting was that
finance division two is also meeting
friday at ten o'clock in the morning
it's the same time yes um with with the
um community college system and the
university system yes correct yes
yeah and we also have a person's
schedule come in
um
that uh that has knowledge on what's
going on with these uh with the credit
and with
the combining merging of these systems
throughout the new england year on the
following friday but hopefully at this
friday meeting working
amongst ourselves and working with them
we can come out
with a short list of folks that might be
able to come in and also offer us some
support and trying to arrive at the end
zone here
right i certainly you know i i recognize
what you're saying rick that there's
there's certainly an urgency and a
timeliness
um you know of this so so uh
i i do hope though we'll be able to have
some representatives from the um from
the the two systems to at least monitor
this um you know well obviously both um
both um meetings
the community college system did
complete a recent study
and hopefully we can find the author of
that study
that uh write that
and
you know and and
bring some folks in from the at this
point we're not going to be able to have
somebody come from in all seven
institutions but we want a
representative of those seven whether it
be susan bjork
or it be it um somebody that's uh
involved in that current study
you're talking about the n-chem study
that's what i'm talking about
and so and there are some great uh uh
points that are mentioned in that that
we should be looking at that maybe
highlight some of the uh
the the elements or components that
finance might want to consider
i know that they're having the other
side other uh information provided to
them
however sometimes it's helpful for
groups like that cliff notes that we
might be able to provide them
so
um so once again put down 10 o'clock um
i recognize there's a conflict with the
delegation
merrimack to the county however
i just feel very uncomfortable where we
are right now with such limited time to
start changing and playing with that
date and also playing with dr mckay
which is finally offered to give us some
his oversight our
understandings of what we need to be
considering looking at in terms of
merger
so with that we'll be starting this out
in about a minute here
whereas i'm presenting this next bill
i'm going to be asking our
representative to chair this particular
meeting
our hearing
you can set that up
okay i think it's uh
that time
1 30
which is the scheduled uh time
we're opening the hearing on house bill
and i will do that
at this time
and
given the number of people
who have signed up to testify
and time
and the fact that we have a
recessed bill still to
deal
with i would like to limit a time to two
minutes for uh speakers
and uh ask committee members to
limit
their
questions especially follow-ups um if we
could
so uh
mr chair mr chair
yes
um could i just make a request that when
you limit um
people's testimony that you at least
give them a 30-second warning and and
say that you're where it's going to be
that there's going to be a 30-second
warning
um you know somewhere on the screen
i just find it very rude to just
mute them so without a warning so and i
know representative leon usually does
that quite well um i'm just hoping we
have that and that it's um some place
where the people that are testifying
know that it's going to be
they're able to see that thank you
i can do that for you um if everyone can
see my screen
i'll let everyone know when there's 30
seconds left um you look uh i don't know
it's very dark in your screen um but
give it a shot
can you see this
where's my screen
can you see that yes that's good thank
you that's what i'll do
i agree i feel like cutting people off
but it's just there's no way to you know
i'm sorry
i would also request that
if people have written testimony
that they state it at the beginning
and that they summarize their written
testimony
thank you
just a a courtesy um
i find i find it very difficult when
people come and wait to speak on any
issue
and then they find out right before they
open the hearing they're going to give
them two minutes
i mean whatever time you're going to
uh mandate and i understand this is a
controversial bill but it really would
have been nice to announce during the
day that i'm not hearing it'll be two
minutes or three minutes so these people
could plan appropriately it just seems
like a that's a hell of a lot of time to
waste you wait around six hours to talk
for two minutes so it says a courtesy
from the house if we know we have a bill
we gonna where you're gonna limit
testimony um then it'd be nice if you
guys anyone told in advance
thank you
okay um
with that um we will recognize the
prime sponsor of karen
thank you very much uh representative
cordelli for the record my name is rick
black
uh representative from april new
hampshire
and i'm here today to speak on behalf of
hp 198
relative to exception to the opportunity
for an education without
and in no way do i want uh to convey
in my testimony that i'm contrary to
354a colon 28 gap in
public education without discrimination
when we look at 354 there are exceptions
for various uh other categories within
this and it's my opinion that
we need to be looking at the possible
exception and dealing with the topic
that i'm going to go ahead and address
at this moment
if an act that this bill will prevent
biological males who claim to be
transgender transgender from competing
against biological females in the high
school and post-secondary in scholastic
and strategic athletics
the bill further supports congress's
intended purpose of creating athletic
opportunities for girls as enacted in
title ix
48 years ago
his response believe that rsa 354 a a
colon 28 the opportunity for public
education without discrimination will be
strengthened with this exception
pertaining to high school and
post-secondary sports
this is in keeping with title ix and
intended to preserve and provide
limit in sports
title ix was created to advance
opportunities for women not biological
men who claim to be with
for title ix purposes sex means
biological sex
boys generally tend to be bigger
taller stronger and faster than girls
and jump higher and straight balls with
greater force
all which gives boys an advantage over
girls supports which schools have
traditionally reserved exclusively for
girls in sports such as field hockey and
military
female track and field
athletes might be considered elite when
compared to other females but their
running times or jumping or throwing
marks often pale in comparison to those
of their male counterparts
in sports like basketball or soccer
a tall strong fast athletic girl who
dominates against other girls would
likely be seriously outclassed when
competing against boys
physiological differences between sexes
do exist
from a competitive standpoint males were
permitted to compete with girls for
positions on girls sports teams
due to average physiological differences
males would displace females to a
substantial extent
in respect to high school level
athletics open competition and would in
all probability relegate the majority of
females to second class positions as
bench warmers or spectators
if it therefore stands to reason by
letting boys even those who claim to be
girls to compete on girls teams
violates the equal protections clause
and denies girls athletic opportunities
provided under title 9.
without a gender-based classification
built upon biological gender competitive
sports there would be a substantial risk
that boys participate in girls programs
would dominate those programs and deny
girls an equal opportunity to
participate in inner splastic events if
an athlete's mere claim that he is
female or vice versa takes precedent
over or at least is equal are given
equal weight with biology then the term
sex is used in typecast and title ix is
rendered useless interpreting the title
ix to require that high schools shop and
rent transgender athletes to compete on
whichever athletic teams match an
individual's self-proclaimed gender
identity would in fact disadvantage
biological women and undermine the
intent and purpose of title ix
if the school has teams available for
persons of his biological gender then
denial to participation on girls teams
is not discrimination in fact if a
biological male is allowed to
participate on a girl's team in this
situation
it is the girls who are being
discriminated against
in summary the disregard of
physiological differences between boys
and girls most often results in
disadvantages and endangers girls on the
athletic field
permitting non-biological girls
participation in girls athletics is
contrary to legitimate and important
government interest in correcting fast
discrimination practices
and enacting equities in competitive
athletics
requiring sex generated teams to include
persons of self-proclaimed gender
identity that does not match their
biological gender would hinder and quite
possibly reverse the steady increase
women's participation in interest in
sports that has taken place due to title
ix
following president biden's recent
executive order on preventing
discrimination on the basis of gender
identity
olympic track and field coach linda
blade spoke
the leadership
the leadership skills
all the benefits society gets from
little girls have their protected
categories so that competition can be
fair all the advantages of women's
rights that's going to be diminished
as a park parent and a grandparent of
girl athletes who have and are competing
at the highest collegiate levels in this
country i am disturbed that our
political system is engaging in
dismantling title ix and all the
exceptional gains made by girls since
1972.
the athletic chasm between sexes which
opens at puberty is both permanent and
unabridged and unbridgeable
once male puberty is complete
testosterone suppression doesn't undo
the biological advances men
possess larger hearts lungs and bones
greater bone density more oxygenated
blood more fast twitching muscle fiber
and vastly greater muscle mass
the fastest female spinner in the world
is american runner alyssa felix a woman
with more gold medals than usain bolt
her lifetime best from 400 meter run is
49.26 seconds
based on 2018 data nearly 300 high
school boys in the u.s alone could beat
that mark
the spectacular records and achievements
that jackie joyner althea gibson and
willman rue of rudolph would never have
been achieved had the world pitted their
bodies against men yet here we are today
hearing a bill that if not pass could
lead to the end of girls sports and
significantly reverse all the wonderful
gains directly associated with title ix
thank you um and thank you for listening
to my presentation
thank you
and to expedite uh time right here i i'm
going to
forgo the question and answer period and
let other folks who want to test why i
have that opportunity thank you thank
you
so with that um
we'll just go
right down the list of people
so um i do have uh representative tim
corrigan it's our practice to let
representatives go there correct
yes okay so um
go ahead mr uh representative
thank you very much i didn't realize i'd
be the first person to speak against
this by representing timothy oregon and
represents stratfor counties district
six to the towns of durham and madbury
and i'm so i strongly oppose this bill
for a
basic premise of uh trans
women not really being women i just
absolutely disagree with um so that's uh
and i mean i'm aware of the fact that
men are
generally bigger and taller and stronger
than women i mean obviously there are
although there are some women who are
much taller than men especially me i'm
only five six but uh i think
i think this is something that should be
left
to the uh you know the athletic
sanctioning bodies the nhiaa has
what i think is fairly reasonable
provision that you have to be you know
a young woman has to be living her life
as a woman for purposes other than just
athletic competition so there's more to
it than just uh you know
saying you're a woman and going out and
competing in a girls high school sport
or college sport and the other
competitions have the same thing i will
say
um this is an issue that's been around
really as long as women are
participating for professional sports so
even back you know
even back in 2030s or any woman excelled
was often suspected of you know expected
of you know being a uh what we now call
a trans you know trans female and uh
most of them
and most so but i don't think any of
them were deliberately doing that just
to gain assists and just because of who
they are they had a famous american
sprinter named stella walsh who
actually everybody except as a female
presented as a woman everybody you know
she was unequivocally a woman was even
married for several years and that she
turned out to
be what they call you know
intersex person so she was like
you know a combination of male and
female and they didn't find out until
she died and that's uh
i mean that that's a that's a fact of
life but uh women but you know she was
still a woman the other women who
competed in the sports are
also also women and you know so this is
just uh
this bill is not as bad as what we have
in other states but
still a bad bill and it should be should
be itl then we should any case leave it
maybe to the various um sports
organizations which have their own
policies and uh will continue to have
their own policies even if we pull uh
full
girl even if we like prohibit
them from public school teams and
finally this also
also impacts you know some activities
which are mostly done by girls but which
uh case make boys participate in like
this might ban example boys from
participating or young men participating
in high school or collegiate cheer teams
so that's um
this
this is a this is a bad bill just create
more more hatred where there's already
too much hatred so i urge the committee
to find this bill and expedient to
legislate um thanks
thank you representative
any questions from the committee
see none help we have represented
oh i'm sorry
sir thank you for taking
[Music]
my question um
questions if you were
anywhere
biological female
[Music]
we're having a little trouble uh you
maybe you're trying without you know
maybe try a little bit better
um i mean i think i
think i heard him maybe i think he's
asking for any
you know journey trans male who had
transitioned from being female and
excelled in
actually um
i'm sure it's happened i i
i do not know so but uh
it's uh certainly there are
certainly there are
trans trans men who start who were
perceived as female earlier
i mean i know for example there is a
previous
when we had this bill which i guess was
in 2019 well similar bill in 2019 we did
have uh some uh
some some young men who were trans men
came in who did participate in support
something either question was uh
whatever you know
i'd like go oh
anybody who's transitioned from male to
female um
i yes there's been a number
there's been
i mean there's a lot of controversy over
that um i remember
the only uh
i do remember there's a female east
german athlete who did uh
transition well there's also like here
in the united states we have bruce
jenner who transitioned from male to
female that's now uh
you know
now uh caitlyn jeff no ugly caitlyn
jenner i can't keep all those genders
straight i believe that's her name i
mean there was one you know there's a
east german
triathlete who later trans with the
other way transitioned to males it
doesn't happen but i'm not uh
i'm i don't know i'm not the expert on
it so probably uh
you probably may have to do your own
research on it before you decide which
way to
vote on the bill but that's uh
thank you that's the best answer yeah
thank you support
next is milano
you've been promoted go ahead and uh
welcome to the application
hi members of the committee uh i want to
appreciate uh you all taking the time to
hear my testimony today my name is
paulana belkin i'm a rochester resident
and a city councilor here who is proud
to call new hampshire my home and i'm
strongly opposed
to hb 198.
in 2020 i authored a report titled the
case for lived quality in the classroom
which was published by the aclu of new
hampshire and that examined the adoption
of the new hampshire school board
association's model trans policy jbab
as well as new hampshire's history of
affirming trans identities mostly
students
in preparing the report i spent most of
last year personally reading through and
analyzing about 196 public school and
charter school policies across new new
hampshire and a little bit of the bigger
picture of trans uh trans rights
statewide
i mean i'd like to just share a few
stats that i kind of took out of this
report in compiling it so over the past
six years 50 school districts across new
hampshire have passed their own trans
student policy so these 50 school
districts they cover about 40 percent of
our state's total public school
enrollees so we have 40 percent of our
students are attending a school
where uh you know one of these 50 times
that that a school board came together
and identified the need for a trans
student policy 50 different times that a
community identified that need for
themselves and passed a policy
um
two observations that i will elevate are
that there's uh there's a really great
geographic diversity amongst these
districts the first two districts to do
so were monroe
and epping um school districts as far
north as ariel as far west as winchester
and keene as well as our schools are our
state's largest school districts nashua
and manchester have all passed
comprehensive transgender student
policies that include athletics
alton gilford nashua and manchester and
muscoma valley all passed their policies
in the last year and a half and those
account for about 15 of our
um of our state's public school
enrollees
when mixed with the in 2010 the nhiaa
said that trans students have the right
and that there is a system of working
that out
i think that it's no mistake that 50
different communities the
nhiaa and the new hampshire state
legislature many times over at this
point there have been so many bills and
updates to it have all arrived at trans
folks deserving full inclusion under the
law
um
you know i also think that it's no
mistake that not once has a complaint
been filed against a transgender athlete
here in the state of new hampshire and i
don't think that it could be any more
clear that hb
198 is a solution in need of a problem
um and i
please encourage you to join me in in uh
in opposing this bill thank you very
much thank you uh
thank you
questions from
me
steven
thank you very much and testimony
okay uh next we have sophia biando lilo
i'm sorry i
didn't get your name correct the last
time welcome back to education
hi can you hear me
yes
all right uh well thank you to the
members of the committee for taking my
testimony today for the record my name
is sofia biandolilo i'm 14 i live in
manchester and i'm speaking today on
behalf of the new hampshire high school
democrats in strong opposition to hb198
um to address what one of the
representatives said i do have written
testimony i will send it to the
committee after this um and if i had to
summarize it in one sentence i guess i
would say that everything in the bill
is based upon has been disproven and it
is openly discriminatory
um so there are two things implying this
bill's findings that i'd like to address
um first is that single set of athletes
single sex athletics are rooted in
biological differences between the sexes
and that is just not true the actual
origin of segregated sports is because
of the um prevailing scientific theory
in the 1800s which was that the human
body had a limited amount of energy and
that if a woman who was menstruating
used any sort of mental energy um while
she was menstruating she could hurt
herself and that is why they were
encouraged only to play recreational
sports that required very little energy
and now we still separate women from
sports but it is completely arbitrary
and it's not based on any real science
because obviously our theory of science
has evolved since then secondly the bill
implies that trans girls have some sort
of inherent advantage over cis girls
which is also not true in 2017 sports
medical did a comprehensive review of
all research and reporting on the
subject and they found that quote there
is no direct or consistent research
suggesting transgender female
individuals have an athletic advantage
at any stage of their transition and
that is exactly what the issue comes
down to the idea that trans girls have
an advantage totally overlooks the
entire purpose of medical transition
many trans athletes use hormone blockers
and or hormone replacement therapy which
lowers their testosterone to typical
levels for their gender this completely
eliminates whatever advantage we might
expect trans girls to have
hypothetically
and to touch on my personal experience
i'm a member of the new hampshire junior
roller derby team which is completely
co-ed our team is very diverse and
includes boys girls non-binary people
tall people strong people and all
different builds and variations within
biology this is not something that
hinders our ability to play but it makes
the game more fun and makes skill more
valuable and if a trans girl wanted to
enter our team we would welcome her with
open arms as every team should
so in conclusion by singling out trans
girls and dividing them from their peers
we endorse transphobia hate bullying and
unproven science and we contribute to
the already stressful experience of
navigating the world as trans in new
hampshire and i urge the committee to
recommend itl on hb198 so as not to
endorse open discrimination against
those most vulnerable in our communities
and to protect trans girls and i thank
you for your time
thank you very much
for your testimony
questions
reflective has her hand raised
yes
yes thank you for taking my question is
there any i loved your example of the
rollerblading is there any reason why we
can't have more uh mixed gender sports
than we do right now which this bill is
not against in any way
and that would provide a place for
um everybody to participate in sports
um i think that you are correct i think
that all sports should be co-ed um but
also i think with the situation where it
is right now when we do have sports that
are divided by gender we should let
people be on the appropriate teams
because they are divided
thank you
thank you very much
next we have megan karen
welcome to education
hello yes can you hear me okay
great my name is megan karen of nashua
thank you for allowing me to testify in
opposition to this harmful bill um i was
raised here in in new hampshire and
before i moved back i was the program
director for a non-profit in boston
working with
youth who were either at risk for
commercial sexual exploitation or were
being exploited at the time
and many of these uh youth were trans
youth and experiencing homelessness
and i'll never forget one client said
some something that a client said to me
when i asked them what led them to
boston they said there was nothing for
me in new hampshire and i want that to
sink in
this particular young person shared that
they would rather be experiencing
homelessness in a city where they can
live as their authentic selves and have
access to resources
than to be in a place where they felt
they were not welcome they were not
accepted nor were they valued new
hampshire is better this than this and
our youth deserve better thank you very
much for your time
thank you and uh nice to see you all
again again uh david dougherty from
pembroke
uh
in the uh interest of time let me just
state that i uh have sent a letter to
the committee
which uh i think sufficiently expresses
my views on this bill i find this bill
to be
discriminatory and onerous
and i would encourage the committee to
itl this bill
and uh thank you for
hearing my testimony please just read my
letter
and have a good day
thank you very much
[Music]
i do not see any so
thank you very much
thank you
next we have chris urchill uh thank you
very much for becoming that education
i think thank you thank you chairperson
thank you members of the committee uh my
name is chris urchel again i'm an
attorney with glbtq legal advocates and
defenders um new england's go to lgbtq
legal advocacy organization i'm also a
new hampshire licensed attorney although
i am based in boston um i'm emphatically
opposed to hb 198 i've submitted
testimony to that effect but i'll go
through some oral points as quickly as
possible
everyone here is concerned about
fairness and school sports programs
there is no disagreement about that
we all also believe in educational
opportunities that must be available to
all students equally i'm going to try to
explain a little bit more about why hb
198 takes away from that goal and why it
doesn't provide any benefit to anyone
transgender girls play sports for the
same reason that any young people play
sports participation in sports provides
necessary opportunities for young people
to develop critical life skills
including communication teamwork
self-discipline leadership confidence
everybody benefits when these
opportunities are available equally to
all students i spoke this morning in a
different hearing and i explained a
little bit about who transgender people
are i made a key point in that hearing
that it's imperative to the health and
well-being of all students to be
affirmed in their gender identity in all
aspects of their life at school this is
true for transgender students and for
non-transgender students that means that
during the school day students should be
affirmed and it means the same for
after-school sports programs every
transgender student must be affirmed and
treated as a whole person
uh today's transgender students our
future neighbors co-workers educators
volunteers parents
and um all right well i see there's only
30 seconds left i'm going to
rush to make a couple of really
important points one is that it's a
misstatement that title nine precludes
transgender girls from playing in sports
programs with boys uh the supreme court
has specifically said that sex
discrimination laws apply to uh protect
people based on transgender status and
also um a conservative judge in idaho uh
appointed by donald trump just last year
uh found one of these bills um
unconstitutional a very similar bill so
um this bill does not pass muster um the
supporters of this bill say it's about
fairness but the truth is it's
legislative overreach it's in search of
a problem that doesn't exist and it
imposes unfairness
i urge you please vote itl on this bill
and i'm
open any questions you have
thank you very much
um
i do not see any questions so thank you
very much for
sticking around today
thank you
next we have
jennifer frazelle i have promoted you
please
good afternoon uh mr chairman and
members of the education committee i'm
jennifer ferzal and i'm here today
on behalf of the new hampshire women's
foundation where i serve as the director
of policy
and we are strongly opposed to house
bill 198
the new hampshire women's foundation
invests in equality and opportunity for
women and girls through research
advocacy and philanthropy
and along with our predecessor
organizations the new hampshire
commission on the status of women the
new hampshire women's lobby and the new
hampshire women's policy institute we've
been a consistent and leading voice for
the advancement and protection of women
and girls here in new hampshire for a
combined 50 years
with regard to issues of sex and gender
discrimination we have a long history as
a leading voice for title ix here in the
state advocating for equity in school
sports opportunity for women and girls
to benefit from athletic participation
and teamwork and competition
the fundamental premise of house bill
that cease gender women and girls are
better served by the exclusion of women
and girls who happen to be transgender
is one that we reject at the women's
foundation and we encourage this
committee to do the same
house bill 198 is state-sponsored
discrimination and promotes exclusion
and unequal access to education
the impact of such discrimination can be
severe and have lifelong harm
for transgender children and youth
compared to allowing them to participate
in recreational support
sports
uh in affirming their gender identity
which can provide an enormous boost to
their self-confidence and their
self-esteem that will help them succeed
in all areas of life
we believe that providing equal
opportunities in all aspects of school
programming should be the core value in
education
this legislation would authorize schools
and districts to violate new hampshire's
nondiscrimination laws that have been
worked on in many uh over recent years
um paulana belkin was able to point out
that for you earlier in testimony so i'm
not going to review those but those
anti-discrimination laws to be inclusive
um of our transgender
sisters are are very important and our
foundation of the women's
foundation's advocacy in this area
uh i want to emphasize uh what chris
urchel just said um the policies
advanced in 198 are actually at odds
with title ix
and the previous testimony about title
ix not being supportive of the
inclusiveness
of transgender women in sports
is not a legal conclusion that's sound
the new hampshire women's foundation is
a state-based organization but when
we're working on issues like this we
look to national advocates as well
so the national women's law center the
national women's sports foundation
uh and the national women's in college
sports are all organizations that are um
behind our position as well i see my
time is up uh we at the women's
foundation urge you to reject this
proposal uh and thank you for the change
yes
today thank you very much
questions from me
representative
i thank you mr
chair and thank you jennifer your
testimony for taking my question would
you believe that i had two daughters who
played soccer at concord high school
and there was a game with against gosh
town where katie and the goffstown girl
were both running full speed for about
50 50 well there was a collision
the other girl suffered a terrible
broken leg ambulance came out
both those girls weighed
115 pounds or whatever or something like
that
would you be concerned about a 180 pound
player born a biological male running
full bore from the other direction
against a
girl who say weighs 110 pounds for a
50-50 blog do you think that 70-pound
disparity would put the smaller girl at
a significant physical risk
well in the research that i've done
around this issue and the experts that
i've looked at you know as well as the
experience i know about adolescents and
the fact that uh children of of all
genders grow at different stages and
sizes and whether or not they're of
different biological sexes that type of
disparity exists i certainly think that
that public safety and the safety of
athletics have gone into the
consideration of policies of expert
organizations like the new hampshire
interscholastic athletic association and
the new hampshire school boards
association and others who have worked
on this and so um i believe that
the safety of participants is already in
the forefront of uh sanctioning policies
like the ones we support
thank you thank you
thank you mr cells
i cannot see any other questions so uh
thank you so much yes
next uh i have
um
blackstone but i do not see gwendolyn i
see a wendy glass so i hope
that
at
hello this is uh gwendolyn gladstone can
you hear me
yes
yes hello i'm gwendolyn gladstone i live
in exeter i'm a retired pediatrician and
i'm speaking today as a representative
of the new hampshire chapter of the
american academy of pediatrics
which
has a membership of over 240
pediatricians in the state
our chapter strongly urges you to vote
house bill 198 inexpedient to legislate
additionally i have been asked by the
new hampshire medical society and the
new hampshire psychiatric association to
let you know that they also strongly
oppose house bill 198
this bill would hurt transgendered
children would be extremely difficult to
implement and is not necessary to allow
non-transgender children a fair chance
to participate in high school and
post-secondary sports
i will be submitting these comments
under a letter signed by our chapter
president eric schestler
like all children it's good for
transgender children to be physically
socially and emotionally
um
for them to be physically active and to
participate in sports with their friends
and peers
being excluded is especially hard for
transgender children because it
aggravates their already high risk for
depression and suicide
house bill 198 would hurt these children
who just want to play on teams like
other kids and who especially need to be
accepted by others
boys who transition to girls may begin
medical treatment at different stages
before reaching puberty boys and girls
do not differ in height muscle or bone
mass there is no evidence that boys
who've begun to transition to girls at
this stage have any advantage in
athletics
optical optimal medical care for these
children is to block puberty so that the
expected rise in testosterone increased
muscle strength and bone density do not
occur
no child in these categories is any
threat to girls playing sports
the mcaa specifically opposes
discrimination against these young
people it also opposes what is sometimes
called sex verification this is the
humiliating and at times medically
impossible task of determining what sex
a person is
implementing house bill 198 would be
similarly humiliating and medically
impossible
not all humans are either male or female
there are people who fall somewhere in
between these two categories into what
is called intersex
sex verification will not work for them
the ncaa said fears that men pretend to
be female to compete on women's teams
are unwarranted given that in the entire
40-year history of sex verification
procedures in international sports
competition no such instances of fraud
have been revealed
additionally the american academy of
pediatrics has a strong stance against
discrimination on this issue therefore
we encourage the committee to vote the
bill itl
thank
you enough
and uh
i'm not seeing so uh thank you very much
for being here
welcome to education
hello um so hi my name is laura lee
godfrey i go by she her pronouns and i'm
16 years old and i'm also the secretary
of new hampshire's legislative youth
advisory council and i'm here today to
speak on their behalf and i also did
submit written testimony as well so the
new hampshire legislative youth advisory
council strongly opposes hb 198 which
restricts individuals assigned male
birth from participating in women's
sports and various testimonies have gone
over this but today i'm also here to
talk about the impacts of this bill if
it were passed uh we argue that this
bill is going to create more problems
than it would solve in that it would
solve none has it all 14 of citations
which i've also linked to in my written
testimony reveals that members of the
transgender community experience
severely high suicide rates influenced
by mental health factors like
discrimination the type of which this
bill would promote and as well as
rejection or gender dysphoria and sports
have long been associated with improving
mental health as evidenced by rosemont
at all 14 and hardy at all 15 and they
find that when access to sports is
diminished trans individuals feel
alienated from their peers and their
physical and social well-being are
harmed and this bill would prevent
gender affirming sports at risk of
isolating trans individuals and
negatively impacting their mental health
so there's no singular case in new
hampshire in which a pla a fair a fair
competitive playing field would not be
guaranteed by sports under current
regulation and as previous testimonies
have mentioned right now the new
hampshire interscholastic athletic
association or the nhiaa already has a
policy that evaluates trans women's
participation in sports on a
case-by-case basis in their policy
statement and school recommendation
regarding transgender participation and
this process resolves issues on an
individual stance that takes into
account gender effort information and
competitiveness so this bill is not
intended to promote fairness in women's
sports because this ignores the current
policies that already address it and
consequently it is solely discriminatory
and harmful it might be said to be done
in order to protect or promote women's
sports but excluding women from women's
sports is not achieving that goal in any
way and allowing trans women
into sports is not a reversal of women's
rights in any way either as
representative vlad said because in fact
it's the actually the ultimate
representation of its promotion and
protection and it is far encompassing in
its attempt to address any issue and
crafting a bill to entirely prevent
transgender women has the potential to
exacerbate mental health issues and
suicide rates in our states and for
these reasons the new hampshire
legislative youth advisory council is in
strong opposition and urges a vote
against hb 198. thank you for your time
and i will answer any questions if you
have them
thank you very much for being here
i just want to say thank you that's the
most information i've ever heard in two
minutes in all my years on this
committee thank you
thank you
thank you uh thank you young lady for
taking my question um approximately how
many people make up make up the council
and where are they uh from
uh so i think approximately 20 people
make up
uh new hampshire legislative advisory
council and uh the application process
is based on picking people from a wide
geographic diversity to ensure each
county in the state is represented
thank you so much
well done by the way
thank you
yeah i was just wondering if uh if you
have a testimony prepared could you send
that into our
education committee uh yes i did email
it to you guys this morning
thank you
thank you mr chair and laura lee nicely
done very
very articulate
and uh easily understandable i have a
question for you regarding the process
by which uh liak
comes to a decision or or whatever about
what to support
so
today you came
on behalf of lyak so am i correct in
assuming that there is discussion among
the members of
lyak regarding what you're going to
support
and the second part of my question is
in your discussion did you become aware
of any
schools or
geographic regions
where
this um was being presented as an issue
uh thank you so much for your question
mullin so yes to answer your first
question there was a vast amount of
discussion on the spill uh there was an
interest group that specifically studied
it and then we brought it to the rest of
the council to go over and thus we
decided to vote against it and then as
to your second question in our research
we did not find any school district or
institution or club sport that had
listed this as an issue so yes thank you
thank you
thank you very much
for the question so uh thank you very
much for
being here
hello thank you for having me
um i
uh
my name is colin goodbread i'm a
resident of hanover i'm here to urge you
to vote no on hb 198 and i have emailed
my testimony to the committee already
um
so i'm a transgender man meaning that i
was assigned female at birth and have
transitioned to living my life as a man
and i'm appalled that the legislators
who are supposed to represent me are
advancing a bill that is unfounded in
medical research would harm vulnerable
students and waste time addressing a
problem that does not exist i am proud
to participate on my school's triathlon
team where i'm fully welcomed on the
team for exactly who i am while my
teammates and i train hard i'm like the
vast majority of transgender athletes
i'm extremely mediocre and certainly not
a threat to anyone's professional
athletic careers trans women and girls
are not taking away anyone's
opportunities for success
indeed a 2015 study by dr joanna harper
found the transgender women performed
similarly to how they had before
transition in comparison to
non-transgender athletes that is the
vast majority of transgender athletes
are like me incredibly average
yet this proposed legislation would
require children who live their lives as
girls and are seen as girls by all of
their friends and family to compete only
against men
hb 198 would be harmful to transgender
students of all ages and their
confidence and mental health
the sponsors of this bill
claim to care about protecting young
women in sports but i'd like you to
consider what other priorities uh
support that claim
if our representatives truly care about
protecting girls we would see them
passing legislation to fund women's
health centers advocating for sexual
assault prevention and working to
improve the underrepresented
underrepresentation of female athletes
in the media not trying to prevent
children from playing sports so let's
start making real progress towards
gender equality and not making up
problems that don't exist in the name of
hate please vote no on hb 198 thank you
for your time and i'm open to any
questions
thank you very much tom
any questions from with me
so uh thank you very much
thank you
hello thank you for having me
so
my name is olivia goodwin and i will be
emailing my full testimony after this
meeting i stand in front of opposition
to this legislation i pole vault and
long jump on dartmouth's track and field
team i am a division one athlete who
does not identify as man or woman though
i am confined to compete on one of the
two gendered teams at my school since
our track program does not have a mixed
team when we compete i understand the
primary fear that male-to-female
athletes may have a physical advantage
on women's teams
the ncaa handbook already has regulation
protecting against competitive advantage
the most recent handbook is published
online from 2011 on page 13 it states
that a trans female athlete may compete
on a women's team without changing the
team's status to mix after she has
completed a full calendar year of
testosterone suppression treatment the
treatment may be in the form of hormone
replacement or surgery which prevents
the body from creating male typical
levels of testosterone in either form
the one year time delay stands this is
according to the 2018 inclusion forum
focusing on transgender athletes placed
within collegiate athletics finally i
would like to note this bill's
interpretation of biological sex as it
defines femaleness and maleness the bill
states that quote these differences
limiting athletic teams on to sex
specific biological teams ensure that
biological females have equal athletic
opportunities the problem with this
interpretation of biological sex is its
erasure of the natural spectrum of
testosterone level in quote biological
females which already allows for some
competitors to have physical advantage
despite fitting into the socially agreed
upon definition of female a more
productive change to athletics would be
to remove
gender categorization apart from
self-defined teams instead of gender
deciding who competes against who
competitors could be competing in tears
which they qualify for by their personal
best on record or perhaps placement
would be determined by physical height
or weight as many sports favor taller
players and some sports already utilize
those regulations think wrestling for
example
the award system would also be modified
to reflect the tiers
taking all this into account i urge
everyone to vote itl on house bill 198
grant trans athletes the right to
compete on their proper team and grant
trans athletes the right to play and
compete thank you
thank you very much
just about nailed the two minutes
uh
any questions
see none thank you very much for being
here
thank you for allowing me time today
i am here and first of all i just want
to say look at how hard these kids are
having to work to convince you to be
able to play on the field
i just have to say that
it's emotional i'm testifying today on
behalf of my three daughters
one specifically who turned 16 years old
this week
she's testified at the state house in
new hampshire for her rights and
continues to actively work for her
rights
as a trans girl in the state of new
hampshire
i continue to be impressed and in awe of
her and all of the folks that have to
fight so hard to just be
here on this earth
when she is not busy being an advocate
for herself she enjoys playing soccer
and downhill skiing
she has participated in the oyster river
school district
and is now continuing her love for
athletics at a private school
high school in our state
as her mom i am here to ask you to
consider that there are many children
almost adults in this state that just
want to play
they want to experience being a part of
a team of peers to improve their
physical abilities
and just find joy
participating
they are not looking to steal medals or
cheat systems
cheaters are always going to cheat
they just want to play
please let my child continue to
participate in in her sports and
athletics in the state of new hampshire
and also on behalf of my cisgendered
daughters
i want to note that
the idea of what they may be
um
put to the test to describe or
um confirm their gender is also a very
upsetting concept as the doctor
previously mentioned
sex verification so is this really fair
to any of the women being questioned on
this bill and i strongly oppose the
passing of this thank you
definitely
no questions
thank you very much
from the aclu
you've been promoted over that days
welcome back
thank you good afternoon thank you mr
chairman and members of the committee my
name is jeannie herreska and i'm the
political director for the american
civil liberties union of new hampshire
i appreciate the opportunity to testify
today in strong opposition to hb 198 and
in the interest of time i'm going to
restrict my testimony to some of the
potential legal consequences of passing
this legislation
as you all know the new hampshire
legislature defeated similar legislation
last year in both the house and senate
since then the u.s supreme court ruled
in bostock v clayton city that
discrimination against someone because
of their gender identity is sex
discrimination
moreover i want to point out that
recently the federal government has made
clear that it intends to enforce title
ix consistent with the supreme court's
holding in postdoc such that any state
that passes a law barring trans students
from activities and spaces that align
with their gender identity will risk
their title ix compliance and the
millions of dollars they receive in
federal education funding i also want to
know at the state level idaho passed
very similar legislation last year and
the state immediately found itself in
court where a judge imposed a
preliminary injunction barring the law
from taking effect
in his decision in that case judge nye
determined that those challenging the
idaho law were quote likely to succeed
in establishing the act as
unconstitutional as currently written
due to the inescapable conclusion that
the act discriminates on the basis of
transgender status the judge noted that
the state had not identified a
legitimate interest served by the act
other than an invalid interest of
excluding transgender women and girls
from women's sports entirely
in sum this extreme policy violates the
u.s constitution and federal civil
rights law puts new hampshire at risk of
losing hundreds of millions of dollars
in federal funding and costing the state
more money in litigation costs
and harms transgender youth and in terms
of litigation costs i will note that the
idaho litigation has already cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
that price tag is rising if the case
ultimately goes to trial we expect it to
cost at least five million dollars in
costs and fees
and in
during a pandemic i would dare sit dare
to suggest that granite staters can
think of much better ways to spend their
tax dollars than on litigation to defend
a bill that violates state and federal
law
i will send in my written testimony i'm
happy to answer questions and i strongly
encourage this committee to vote itl on
hb 198.
thank you very much
i uh see no
mr questions
yeah thank you very much and thank you
very much mr oscar for joining us this
afternoon on that so um you know looking
looking beyond the just the the blatant
um unfairness and discrimination that
that's at work here
i was wondering if you could break down
the the financial
impact in terms of loss of loss of
federal funds both on the
primary secondary and um and
post-secondary educational systems
i don't have those numbers though i
strongly encourage this committee to
take a close look at those numbers um
i'll just reiterate that again since the
supreme court's decision in bostock
courts have repeatedly held that title
ix prohibition on sex discrimination
prohibits discrimination against
transgender students
so this bill will violate title ix
and so any funding that the state gets
from the federal government that
requires compliance with title ix would
be threatened
uh were this bill to pass
so fault follow up on that mr chair
so um so not only would that affect um
title four
um um student federal student loans but
could that also affect um um the
hundreds of millions of dollars in
research grants i believe so yeah this
bill applies to
post-secondary education um so i think
the state should take a very careful
look at all the education funding it
gets from the federal government before
it contemplates passing this bill
thank you very much
okay
um
uh hello my name is elaine jocelyn i was
born in portsmouth and i'm currently a
sophomore in high school i also happen
to be a transgender girl um
as you can see i am five feet six inches
tall and 100 pounds i hope you don't i
hope you understand that i don't pose
any physical threat to anyone else on
the soccer field
i absolutely love the sport of soccer
i've played for the last 10 years and
i've played on the girls soccer team for
the last five years
playing soccer has always been the
highlight of my day each summer and fall
it's my opportunity to work out to
collaborate with other girls with the
same passion and just have fun
i usually play santa striker
last year the extra girls university
team had just suffered a huge loss
against our rival andover we all we were
all crying on the way home and hugging
each other in consolation
then one of my team captains started
playing
a party in the usa on a speaker a pop
song by miley cyrus needless to say
everybody knew the song soon we were all
laughing up from our seats waving our
hands around screaming the lyrics
we were all laughing and singing the
notes totally off key but it was a
complete blast our mood shift and our
mood shifted from miserable to joyful i
loved every minute minute of it
sharing this thing of the loss trying to
figure out what we could have done
better and a short time later getting
over the pain and simply loving being
teammates is it is one of my most
cherished memories
please don't deny other transgender
girls the opportunity to have these
experiences and the ability to be on a
team just having fun and learning about
sportsmanship
everyone should be able to participate
whether regardless of their gender
identity
and fyi not one person on my soccer team
last year knew i was transgender but if
they had known i can guarantee you they
wouldn't have cared hopefully that shows
just how little it matters thank you for
your time
thank you very much
questions
you very much
okay
okay next we have elizabeth
just motivated
okay great my name is elizabeth leahy
and i am here to testify in opposition
of hb um
198.
in 2019 the state recognized that all
people regardless of a number of bases
including gender and gender identity
have the right to fully participate in
enjoy the benefits of and be free from
discrimination in public schools new
hampshire codified these rights in new
hampshire law
the bill today seeks to roll back the
recognition of these rights and create
an exception to these
anti-discrimination protections the
government is wrong anytime it seeks to
walk back rights and legalize
discrimination against a targeted group
of people
i am a lifelong athlete and including
was one at the division one level
i'm acutely aware of the value of school
athletic programs that they provide to
all students but particularly girls
leadership confidence teamwork and
discipline all girls are entitled to
this opportunity and especially so
within our public schools
though the stated goal of the bill is to
preserve girls athletics if implemented
it would actually hinder and set a
ceiling on girls athletics
inherent in the bill is a proposition
that girls are superior to boys and that
if a girl is too good she must not
really be a girl
we see this nationally and
internationally with athletes like
castor semena and even serena williams
bills like this create a framework to
gatekeep women womanhood and all women
suffer under these types of restrictions
lastly this effort is rooted in fear and
entitlement and not in science or
reality
nowhere in this country are trans
athletes dominating any level of
athletics instead trans people are like
cis people some are very good athletes
and some are bad athletes very few are
exceptional athletes capable of
dominating competition
as we
as a society continue to broaden our
understanding of what it means to be a
woman we must actively reject feelings
that something to which we feel entitled
is being taken away
trans women have the right to
participate and succeed in something
athletics or otherwise without being
accused of taking from cis women
rather than teaching kids that they've
been harmed when somebody has finally
afforded an opportunity after long being
denied it we should teach them the
importance of recognizing others
humanity i thank you for the opportunity
to speak and i ask you to itl the bill
thank you
thank you for your testimony
no questions so
thank you
thank you very much
for closing
hi
um thank you for your time and attention
um i think everything that i would like
to say has pretty much been covered my
transgender daughter has never been
through male puberty and she has less
testosterone in her body than a typical
girl according to her pediatric
endocrinologist
so she has no physical advantage over
anyone
um as a high school athlete myself i
understand how important the work ethic
the goals the skills
being outside um you know just being
part of a sports team how critical that
is to development for teenagers and kids
and
there's no reason why all three of my
children shouldn't be able to
participate in that that one should be
singled out so
i i'm gonna wrap it up there because i
think um you know my point of view has
been covered very well by so many
different people but i would just want
to add that when i hear legislators in
new hampshire
discuss transgender people and say that
they're pretending to be
girls or claiming to be girls it makes
me realize there's a lot of education
that needs to be done and i would urge
the legislators who don't understand
what it means to be transgender to dig a
little deeper and try to get educated
because it's very insulting to hear that
kind of language thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
i guess um
you signed in in support of this bill
all right
[Music]
oh yes no i oppose this bill i'm i'm
sorry maybe i clicked the wrong box my
apologies
thank you representative
uh mr claude thank you for taking my
question uh does your transgender
daughter participate in in sport now
whatever at whatever level she's at
yes she does it's been a huge
um
you you actually met her that's lane is
my daughter oh okay okay
so yeah i'm very proud of her and um and
um i just i can't emphasize enough how
important sports has been to her feeling
part of her community and um
you know i think that that that her
social transition that happened in fifth
grade really changed her life to be able
to be
her authentic self and be the happy kind
loving smart kid that she is very um
engaged and um you know she hadn't
socially transitioned at that time
um you know like people have said the
the outcomes are not what they are when
they get full acceptance not just from
family but from school communities and
the greater community and this as a
business owner in portsmouth this would
be a big black eye for our state if one
follow-up is the chair for me
i'll be quick thank you mr mccall one
more question uh in the parent community
which i'm sure you're involved in around
your youngsters
uh is there a dialogue is there talk one
way or the other
oh absolutely i mean i think that the
genie's point that this will cost the
state a lot of money is very accurate
there is a large mama bear community
of of
parents and fathers as well who really
um understand that we need to have our
kids backs and we will go to the mat for
them the i mean if this if this if
governor sununu i don't believe he would
ever sign this but if this became law
there would be lawsuit after lawsuit
thank you so much i appreciate your time
thank you
welcome to education
thank you thank you for recognizing me
mr chair and for the rest of the
committee
my name is ani malachi i am the
executive director of the human rights
commission and i will take my two
minutes and move as quickly as possible
just to give you
a brief understanding of who we are and
what we do
we do not we the commission do not have
a position on this bill
my conversation is really to just um
give you a little information of what it
is that we do and to certainly answer
any questions the committee may have
so in case people are not aware the
human rights commission was established
in 1965
by rsa 354-a for the purpose of
eliminating discrimination in the areas
of employment housing public
accommodation and as of 2019
sb 263 added k-12 education into our
statute
and um and previous to that in 2018
hb 1319 added sexual orientation to uh
to the statute
the commission is comprised of seven
volunteer commissioners who provide
oversight and make decisions on charges
of discrimination
each commissioner is appointed by the
governor with the consent of the
executive council for a term of five
years
the commission has the power to receive
investigate
pass upon complaints of illegal
discrimination and to engage in research
education and community outreach
designed to prevent discrimination
in addition to the authority vested in
the commission by rsa 354-a we enforce
new hampshire's laws against
discrimination
and we also partner with the eeoc which
is also known as the equal employment
opportunity commission to enforce
federal laws prohibiting discrimination
and employment as well
um very quickly
so
what
if hb 198 is to pass um certainly the
commission will follow
the lead of the legislature and we will
enforce whatever laws you put on the
books
ultimately the hrc would request clarity
in our statutory language as to who can
bring a claim who and what grounds
to avoid any conflict
so this would actually create potential
conflict within the statute as to
protection and and no protection um and
there is no way to know what the federal
laws would potentially be
moving that are moving through congress
and we would like to make sure that we
are congruent with federal law and that
we are not
out of step with what the federal law is
and that we're not creating any
confusion here within new hampshire
thank you very much for your time if you
have any questions for me relative to
354-a i'm happy to take them at this
time
thank you very much
for being here
questions from me
so uh
all right
really quick thank you very much for uh
answering the question did you send in
testimony
i did not
is there would you i can certainly email
what i read
oh our statute
certainly i can i can email you the
statute and then i can give you the
bills that i the two bills that i
mentioned
uh one in 2018 one in 2019 if you would
like
thank you very much okay thank you
thank you
next we have um
amy manzelli and i believe there are
a couple of man's alleys
testifying
welcome to education
hi there
sorry about that my computer just
blinked out on me
uh good afternoon
chair ladd members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to provide
testimony today on behalf of myself and
my husband chad turmell
we did submit a letter over email stated
march 6. so i'm sure you've got that in
your record
the letter details three things which
i'll just touch on briefly because i
know you have that it talks about the
rich sports history of our family
the process that our transgender
daughter has gone through to come out
and the risks to her well-being if this
bill were to pass
beyond that i wanted to get into a few
details first two points that are not in
my letter to correct the record
being transgender
is a legitimate
medical condition
diagnosed by a licensed provider
it's called gender dysphoria
secondly
the alleged distinctions that
representative ladd made
as between um
different gendered people
are false
all trans children
like my daughter who transition before
puberty especially
i have no difference in any of those
measures with respect to athletic
performance
so i just wanted to cover a couple
points um highlighting from my letter
if this bill is passed
our transgender daughter
will never
have the right to play sports in school
not at middle school where she is right
now
not at high school
and not at college
she will not have the right to play on a
girls team
and she would never play on the boys
team because she's not a boy she's a
girl
this would be fundamentally unfair to
her
our daughter has the right to be
included
in girls sports
now as i said the letter describes her
coming out but i wanted to highlight
something because it really reinforces
how real this is
her journey began at age three
when you know out of nowhere what she
wanted for christmas
was for santa claus to make her a girl
and of course being a girl and now that
she's grown up a little bit
she wants to play girls sports and when
it's not a global pandemic hopefully
she'll have the right to do that and i
wanted to touch on the connection with
covid because it hasn't been mentioned
yet and it's incredibly important
as we are
hopefully
heading towards a lessening of
restrictions of the pandemic this coming
academic year
it will be the most important time
in my daughter's life i will see that
this is time let me just wrap up this
point as quickly as i can
she likes so many of our children
has been isolated from the social and
emotional growth that comes with
full-time in-person school and
extracurriculars it's nobody's fault
that's been you know taken away from her
and so many other kids but it makes next
year so important as she enters sixth
grade at three rivers school she becomes
eligible for lots and lots of sports
teams
unless of course a bill like this has
passed and becomes law
so there's a few more points in my
letter and i commend those to your
attention
but as a parent of a transgender student
you know my husband and i we're in that
mama bear papa bear club
please
do not take away our daughter's right to
engage in sport i thank you for your
time and i welcome questions
thank you very much
questions
from the committee
so uh thank you very much for your
testimony
thank you
we have um
i'm not sure
yeah i don't see any
others
the the gene manzelli and jenny manzeli
are in the house and you could take them
now if you chose to they are also
you know equally amenable to testify
later
okay well um
scheduled for right now
just take one moment thank you
thank you all here comes jenny
hi everyone
thank you for this opportunity to
testify
honorable chad chair ladd and members of
the committee i jenny mancelli resident
of public new hampshire i'm here to
respect your request that you vote down
house bill 198
i'm here today to stand up and support
my transgender niece
i happen to live with a chronic disease
called predatory angioedema but that's
not what i'm here to talk about today
however living with this chronic disease
has left me with the emote emotional
traumatizing scars
i've been hospitalized several times and
each experience i've had to endure a
sense of vulnerability alienation
exposure and invasion of my privacy
and there's a stigma that i carry on my
shoulders because of this disease
i ask you to take a step back
would you want that same feeling
for your nephew or niece
how would you explain to any child that
because of the fact that other people
choose to be perhaps narrow-minded or
uncomfortable
that she is the one who has to suffer
and undergo this outrageous exclusion
my niece is a girl
more girlier than me perhaps
denying her and other girls like her the
right to play sports would have a direct
correlation to increased suicide rates
unsupported transgender women are among
the highest ranked individuals to commit
suicide
how could you how would you feel if my
transgender niece who's already
struggling
with bullying depression and anxiety
if she attempted to take her life
because of being deprived the benefit of
playing sports
if my niece cannot play on a girl's team
what is she supposed to do she's a kid
children are supposed to run around with
their peers
get dirty scrape their knees
how can she get the proper mental
physical and social social development
if she does not have the opportunity to
interact with your peers on the
basketball court or on the soccer field
or at the starting line
we all want the same for our children
and families we want them to grow to be
successful adults and contribute to the
community in a positive way
now is the time for people like my niece
to learn the value of teamwork fair play
communication
and respect for others and the ability
to follow rules and to cultivate
independence and leadership
thank you so much
for considering to vote down
house bill 198 thank you very much
enough questions
good morning
afternoon
another man's alley
good morning honorable chair lad and
members of the committee
my name is jean manzelli i live in
concord new hampshire
and i am here today to adamantly oppose
hb 198
i'm not an attorney
nor am i a politician
i'm just a simple grandmother to a
beautiful transgender granddaughter
i come with a lot of experiences that
relate to today's discussion
with a message of importance to you all
i would like to present you with a
perspective
one that you possibly have not
considered as of yet
i married in 1972 to a man whose path in
life was just beginning how does this
relate to the proposed bill we are here
to debate let me explain
as it turned out my husband became a
beloved high school coach for the sport
of lacrosse for 35 years
i was totally unaware of the benefits of
being a member of a sports team
but over the years i became witness to
the countless children
whose lives were changed forever just
from being actively involved in the
school sport
there were the children who felt
insecure with low self-esteem
there were the children who were heading
towards a troubled and possibly criminal
path
there were the children who were trying
to survive the many kinds of unfortunate
family situations
that they had to endure
there were the children who were a bit
fooled themselves and needed to
understand
there is no eye in team there were the
children who were depressed deflated and
felt alone
these there are many other scenarios but
you get the picture
the very biggest benefit for all these
children which i witnessed on endless
occasions was the opportunity for
college education to those who never
thought that was possible for them
so many became recipients of athletic
college scholarships which shaped their
lives forever
all as a result of their hard work and
dedication to a teen school sport
atmosphere
a small example of how these children
grew up and went on to impressive
careers and lives
is that when my husband passed away the
condolences came
from all over the world including
an official documented moment of silence
in the massachusetts state house
over the 35 years of being involved in a
school sport we saw children
grow up and become educated productive
and responsible adults
this all boils down to school sports
and all the lessons that they learned on
a team
and how that benefited them for their
whole lives
not just until the doors closed after
they graduated
and now you are considering denying all
of these immeasurable benefits to a
selective group of children
do you understand my message today i
hope that i have conveyed to you what
the wonders results of being involved in
this school team can be
this is what i wanted to bring to the
table today a different but very
important view of how children will be
affected as this bill passes
please don't deny the opportunity to
possibly change their entire adult lives
just because of gender identity it is so
terribly unfair to them
as i stated my husband the coach passed
away
if you were still here today you would
be standing beside me and defending our
very special
transgender granddaughter and her rights
she is just beginning the experience of
being a team member in a sport it should
not be taken away from her
simply because of the whims of a group
of misinformed
hateful and discriminatory people
please don't be the reason for this
happening with the passage of this bill
thank you for listening to me
i see no questions
thank you very much
okay next we have uh
maria perez
thank you for uh
thank you thank you mr chair and all
members of the committee for uh let me
um
speak on this bill i'm calling against
this bill
i believe we have enough discrimination
against transgender people
against people of color against all
people here we don't need any more bills
to discriminate
we need people to unify we need right
now is the time for us to work to unify
our communities
to make everybody feel welcome
especially the kids
i heard all these testimonies my heart
is crying my heart is broken we don't
need these kids to go through this
horrible situation that they have to go
through just to explain themselves why
they have the right to be played in
sports
we we don't have the right to be told
you you were born as a boy and you were
born as a girl
we have to respect whatever they want to
be in life
and i will ask this committee please
vote note on this bill thank you so much
for the opportunity to speak up
and i will take any questions
thank you representative
i do not see any questions but uh thank
you very much for being here
thank you very much for the opportunity
thank you
next one
i think this might be
um
can you hear me
hi sorry can you hear me
okay hi
thank you for taking my testimony in
opposition to hb19198
my name is abby maxwell
i live in concord and i am representing
myself
growing up each winter i had the
opportunity to be on a ski racing team
in a dark childhood it was my brightest
spot
and i know that much of the confidence
that carried me to adulthood was born
directly from it
now i have the privilege of skiing with
my daughter who is eight
this year we have frequently skied while
school teams are practicing
she asks about how fast they go
and then she asks if she will be able to
race like that when she is older
i tell her that of course she will
knowing i will have to work so hard to
make my words true
my daughter has a good happy childhood
but she does not have an easy one
in second grade she was bullied for her
gender so much that the aclu and glad
had to step in and our family had to
move to keep her safe she lives with the
knowledge that some people will not like
her because of who she is
she knows that her rights are never a
given
this is a lot for an eight-year-old to
carry
yet somehow
against all odds
my daughter continues to know that to be
transgender is a rare but wonderful
thing
yet my husband and i hold fast to all
the areas where we see her confidence
grow
we don't just put money aside each year
so she can ski because it's fun
we do it because we know the statistics
that result from living in a culture
that tells her from so many angles that
she is wrong
different and unworthy
we know that something as simple as
skiing could save her life
my daughter is a girl
she will not grow up to race with the
boys
and to ask her to is an act of bullying
and exclusion
so before you vote i would urge you to
imagine what it might be like to look
into my daughter's eyes
and to tell her that no in fact she will
not be allowed to race or play any sport
when she is older because adults in her
community believe there is something
dangerous about her
if you did that you would be forced to
see how cruel this bill is
i urge you to oppose hb 198
and instead to continue the work of
building a new hampshire that lives up
to the values we all try to teach our
children
thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
i do not see any questions so um
welcome to education
um
hello
hi i'm ryan
okay just making sure that that works uh
so i am
emily from dover here opposing hp129
uh i'm a transgender woman myself i'm a
doctoral student at unh working on my
degree phd in physics
and i've also been a distance runner for
the last 10 years since i was in high
school myself i was on cross-country in
high school and i've been running ever
since
uh i'd like to object to the notion that
trans women would dominate women's
sports i've been in the same sports
before and after transition
and as was previously stated trans
people tend to
perform
similarly
pre-transition as they do a
post-transition
uh pre-transition my run times for a 5k
which is five kilometers roughly 3.1
miles
uh was about 28 minutes pre-transition
which is roughly slightly below average
for male 1
standards
i actually ran one yesterday uh which is
i timed it 37 minutes which as it turns
out is slightly again slightly below the
female average
for
uh 5k times for women in my age bracket
so
my experience alone just says that it is
very misguided to operate on the
presumption that being transgender would
automatically give me an advantage for
me it certainly does not
and and thus a bill that
is such
predicated on such a generalization i
think is very much a mistake
but having also been a distance runner
for the last decade i will say that
participating in sport has been a
tremendous benefit both to my scholastic
achievement and my mental health
uh when i am struggling with problems in
research comprehensive exams or other
coursework related to graduate school i
will sometimes go out and run just for
two hours just to clear my head and
get my endorphins up i've found that's
been invaluable to my studies and my
career success long term i also have
plenty of wonderful memories from my
time as a high school student and all
the friends that i made
running cross-country back then and i
would hate to deny any future future
trans girls and trans women the same
opportunities that i would have that i
was afforded in running sports
especially because um i know that
had i figured out sooner than i did that
i was trans i definitely would not have
wanted to participate on any boys teams
so given that in good conscience i
cannot support a bill like this and urge
the committee to vote against it
thank you very much for your testimony
i see no questions so
thank you good afternoon thank you
okay next we have battle lawyer welcome
to education
hi thank you everyone here let me start
my video
um thank you for uh hearing my testimony
and uh thanks to emily i'm happy happy
to follow a fellow distance runner so
i'm val moyer i'm a former collegiate
runner at university of vermont and i'm
currently a phd candidate in women's
gender and sexuality studies and my
dissertation looks at transgender
participation policies at the
international level for women's track
and field so i am here today to strongly
oppose this bill
i'm also open to
questions on my research but i chose to
go
for a more personal route for this
testimony
i'm a cisgender woman meaning that i
identify with my assigned sex at birth
and in high school i trained hard and i
was good at running but i was far from
state podiums in my home state of
virginia i wasn't making headlines no
one knew my name
but i got recruited to a division one
program on a partial scholarship
i bring this up to say that thanks to
title ix there are spots and
scholarships thousands of them across
the country for women who do well
in high school sports and that this
should absolutely not be the main point
of high school sports which should
be supportive and inclusive spaces for
everyone
but the idea that trans girls are
somehow swooping in and dominating
is ludicrous it's a scare tactic that's
not based in reality because one trans
girls are girls and two because
recruiting on college teams is an
individual process which mostly depends
on communication between college coaches
and prospective athletes
so
during my time at uvm um the ncaa has
had a trans-inclusion policy in place
since 2011 and many people including
myself have worked hard in the decades
since to ensure that this was followed
on the ground within athletic
departments so that all student athletes
feel welcome and accepted on their team
this bill would undo all of that work
and it would move us backwards
all the effort in writing and
legislating this bill is frankly a waste
of time and it's only harmful
it is addressing a problem that doesn't
exist there are many problems facing
women's sports from sexual harassment to
inequitable funding media coverage
gender equity in coaching and
administration but trans girls and women
competing are not one of those problems
as a society we need to accept the fact
that trans women are women and trans
girls are girls
so then the question boils down to
should girls be allowed to compete with
other girls and the answer is yes
therefore
i cannot
support this bill going forward into the
legislation
thank you
no questions so uh
thank you thank you uh representative
cordelli uh and thank you miss moyer for
coming in and testifying you referenced
research that you've done and it sounds
like you've devoted a fair amount of
time to the topic
is it possible do you have any
sort of reference sheets or uh
cliff notes on on data if you will that
you could send to the committee
regarding the number of incidences and
outcomes
yeah absolutely um i can pull kind of a
lit review and send it um to the
committee for sure but i do want to
clarify i heard a couple questions at
the beginning
there have not been any instances in the
history of women's sports of modern
women's sports of um
people transitioning to female simply
for for the purpose of performance
advantage um that has not happened
i can say that outright so thank you so
much thank you
thank you for joining us
thank you
excellent all right thank you very much
my name is james porter i'm a resident
of manchester new hampshire i've also
been a youth sports coach for the last
25 years
including high school cross-country and
track
i'm a member of the manchester school
board although i'm not here representing
them today but we did pass a
transgender non-binary policy that i'm
very proud of uh and i'm also married to
a physician who in 2004 was voted the
top family practice doc in the state by
her peers so when we were discussing
this policy i did a really really deep
dive i'm a bit of a research dork
and really got into it and i'm here
today to strongly oppose this bill
uh on three basic points number one is
the law
as we heard earlier in the bostock
supreme court ruling which was six to
three
trump appointed justice neil gorsuch
said it was illegal to discriminate
based on gender identity and the
constitution guarantees the right of
equal protection under the law so i
believe that this is illegal on a
federal level
number two i think uh it's important to
really listen to the doctors and i know
we heard a someone from the american
academy of pediatrics
their 2018 report
stated that trans kids face disparities
from inequitable laws and policies
social discrimination access to health
care and opportunities for successes and
they urged lawmakers to pass
proactive policies and protections that
promote inclusion
and safety including access to bathrooms
clubs
high school sports teams locker rooms
and everything that corresponds with
their gender identity so from
listening to the doctors about what they
think we need to do about the kids that
are most at risk
they seem to be fully in support of that
also in terms of like the the locker
room policy i think it's important to
note for the safety of kids
there's a huge component about sexual
assault that happens
and if you pass policies that give them
protections
you basically decrease their risk of
being sexually assaulted and i think
that's important
lastly is just the human element i've
coached transgender athletes
and i can tell you from the bottom of my
heart they just want to be on a team
they want to go to a pasta party on a
friday night they want to high-five
their teammates and talk about watching
the office on netflix the night before
um
and seeing the reaction of parents you
know at team parties i mean they were
crying because for the first time in
their life
their kid felt a connection to other
kids and i i just think that this policy
is a hundred percent wrong and you know
other people have said things uh you
know it's a solution in looking for a
problem and that's basically it there is
no domination going on i haven't seen it
in 25 years transgender athletes have
been around this whole time
um so i i strongly uh oppose it and i'm
willing to take any questions uh and i
have an answer for a previous one if the
chair would allow thank you
um
can you make that point
sure uh some somebody had asked if there
was ever a trans man
that had quote unquote dominated and
chris moser uh is a three-time national
champion in the biathlon and the
triathlon and has represented the united
states at the net at the international
level six times um so that that has that
has happened thank you
thank you very much i see no questions
so uh thank you for your testimony
but
excuse me can you hear me now
yes
okay i'm dr jennifer smith i'm a retired
family physician
um and i'm here to oppose this bill and
i have sent in testimony i hope that you
will read it there is a link to an
article there and i will emphasize that
because everything else i have
come to say has been said before and i
don't want to reiterate but all of the
other opposition is quite correct
there is this question about whether
there is an advantage if perhaps someone
transitioned partway through
their
high school or junior high
from having had testosterone and while
there might be some temporary advantage
it clearly is something that would turn
around and i would also point out that
exogenous testosterone that is
testosterone given
by injection or by transcutaneous
patches
is something that a girl who was born a
girl could use too
if someone was really intent on cheating
but in fact when people's testosterone
is suppressed as all transgender girls
will want their testosterone suppressed
um then it goes down and it does not
continue the advantage and we all know
that the skeletal
differences height and so forth are are
really very much a broad spectrum and
much overlap
um and the article that i sent you um
suggested that if you were going to use
levels
of
hormones to decide who could compete as
a girl that maybe the upper limit of
testosterone should be five
but it also pointed out that in fact
most women
fully pubertal girls and women are at
1.7 or less
so there's actually a marked disparity
and that's because there are a small
percentage back to a fairly decent
percentage of women and girls who have
polycystic ovary syndrome
which causes high levels of testosterone
and in fact they are over represented
among elite athletes
so there is in fact the possibility that
the girls in connecticut who are
objecting to trans girls running against
them
were in fact themselves at higher
testosterone levels than the trans girls
they were competing against
so this is kind of a strange bill
that has no basis in fact and you need
to itl it thank you and i'd be happy to
take any questions
thank you very much
i uh do not see any questions so thank
you very much i appreciate your time
i don't see her either
is going to take a second
good afternoon
um can you hear me
great
good afternoon chairman lad and
honorable members of the committee thank
you for the opportunity to testify
i know that you've heard a lot of
testimony and opposition
on this bill this afternoon and i'm here
to add
to that opposition
my name for the record is courtney
tanner i'm the director of government
relations at dartmouth-hitchcock
and dartmouth hitchcock
cares about this bill because we are the
home to the only pediatric endocrinology
program in new hampshire
i want to raise up um i won't take too
much of your time again i know you
you've heard a lot of opposition but i
want to raise that jessica smith our
program coordinator of the pediatric and
adolescent program at dh's
endocrinology program has submitted
written testimony for the full committee
uh jessica is a practicing aprn and um
jessica has outlined clinical reasons
for for dartmouth hitchcock's opposition
to house bill 198
and um would urge you to
review her written testimony
in addition to jessica's testimony i
would like to offer our clinical team
they our clinical team is eager to
answer any questions that the committee
has and while you contemplate house bill
198 i'm happy to take questions but i'm
even more happy to serve as a connector
to our clinical team
thank you
questions for
okay jonathan welcome to education
go ahead please
thank you
thank you hi
my name is jonathan weinberg um i'll
make this brief because i think everyone
else has had various substantive uh
testimonies i'm a recently elected
member of the concord school board but
i'm speaking my capacity as an
individual and not on behalf of the
board
i think
we've heard a very heart-wrenching and
also very impactful testimonies from
everyone and just as public servants
especially as one in education i'm
committed to using my position to fight
to make new hampshire schools more
inclusive and
equitable for all students
as i imagine each of you are fighting
for your constituents who would be
adversely impacted by the passage of
this legislation
protecting the rights of students should
be a primary duty of elected officials
legislators and community members
i just urge everyone to think about the
stories you heard today
and
think about how everyone will be
impacted and i urge you to
vote this bill and expedient to
legislate
thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony
can you see my questions
thank you
[Music]
um
are you still there
yes i'm here just give me one moment i
gotta
this morning
okay
also i apologize my voice sounds worse
i'm just kidding
good afternoon members of the education
committee thank you for referring me to
the opportunity today i was informed of
the bill this morning and i'm speaking
off the cuff and strong opposition of hb
198.
my name is tristan mclean
from new hampshire and i'm speaking on
behalf of black lives matter north
country this bill was founded in
disinformation and for the sake of not
reiterating the articulated and
impressively prepared testimonies prior
the foundation of this bill is overtly
oppressive discriminatory
unconstitutional and on ostracizes the
transgender
community beyond what they currently
experience
as previously stated transgender
students are not at a physical advantage
in their respective sport despite
biological gender new hampshire is
afflicted with an agent population issue
and we need to itl bills like this
to make sure every citizen feels welcome
and has their humanity respected i
strongly compel the education committee
to itl beyond the previously stated
information and the fact that it's
another roadblock being introduced
through suppressed and oppressed
constituents of your respective
districts it disrespects the humanity of
our youth and introduces just another
trauma to carry on their shoulders later
you've experience every experience they
deserve before entering the workforce
and the destructive world that they're
going to be further exposed to
and for every student here today i want
you to know
you are loved you are appreciated and
you are supported i implore you to keep
on advocating for your rights and know
that you have so many supporters for
your existence while being in safety
i did not and will not prepare a written
testimony as i have other
authentications today sadly and i want
to thank the committee for affording me
this
you very much for uh
good yeah
i did not see the questions so uh thanks
very much
thank you
okay
next we have madness
okay welcome to education
go ahead please
yes here
well uh did you call beth scare
yeah
thank you
yeah so um i'm calling in to support um
hb198
um i'm calling on behalf of all the
women
in new hampshire
that
deserve to have our own sports and
specifically hear the
girls and women who attend public
schools in new hampshire
yes
point of order mr chair
is she in fact representing all the
girls in public excuse me in public
schools
i i don't think she is uh she said she's
representing herself i believe
yes
i am representing myself but i'm calling
on behalf of all the
women and girls in new hampshire um we
deserve better than to have our spaces
and sports taken over
by boys and men
boys and men can have their own spaces
their own sports no one's telling these
kids
that they can't compete in sports
but we are telling male-bodied men
male-bodied people
to please
stick stick with
bone sports your own spaces
we don't need
you in ours
and we know men and boys are much
stronger much bigger much faster the
some of the science i heard
is incredibly
mistaken uh that's all i'll say and
we know
we know why men and women have separate
sports everyone knows
and
new hampshire
should pass a bill
that protects women and gives us a right
to our own sports
please us vote otp on hv198 thank you
thank you very much
any questions for that
i did not see any so uh thank you very
much for being here
i think you have uh
one more one more
welcome to education
don't go ahead please
hi can you hear me
thank you thank you uh chairman ladd
representative cordelli and committee
members
um i don't have
much to add to
the powerful testimony that you have
heard
against this bill
it is not unusual when
non-discrimination is achieved by a
variety of minorities
for there to be pushback
this bill is that kind of pushback
but i think it's important to remember
that
minorities have worked hard to achieve
equality have worked hard to achieve
non-discrimination
and that
that non-discrimination should not be
undone
on in august of 2019
uh governor sununu
signed house bill 608 the
transgender non-discrimination bill
that was supported in a bipartisan way
from the house and from the senate
i urge you to oppose this bill and
support
the non-discrimination bill that has
been passed to support the transgender
community throughout our state
um i'm happy to take questions
but i just wanted to reinforce uh the
powerful testimony that's been given
throughout the day thank you
thank you
no questions
so uh thank you
and i believe that that is
our last
[Music]
i can't hear
could you repeat that mr chair
yeah
is that
could you repeat the support and oppose
it was unclear
um
thank you
so that will end our hearing on uh hp
98 for today
maybe it's for
thank you very much
representative uh yes we're going to
uh go back now and take up hb 276 this
is the bill relative to availability of
menstrual hygiene products and schools
that also has a second part in that bill
which is in the analysis that this bill
also provides the school districts may
seek state reimbursement
to fulfill this obligation
so with that i believe we have uh six
people that were signed up to um testify
on that particular bill on this bill
and um
it looks that way
and he did not have the sponsors to
introduce it was introduced by ralph
holm representative bone so at this
point in time i'm opening it up now to
those folks that um
indicate that they like to testify on
behalf of that
let's recognize representative edwards
okay go ahead
yeah hello uh this is representative
jess edwards representing auburn chester
and sandown uh i'm here today uh
introducing hb 276
uh i've talked to the committee before
on
pretty much exactly the same ground so
much of this is gonna be a repeat and
therefore i can i can go through it
pretty quickly i think um
it's a very similar
to a representative judy aaron's bill
that she that she introduced like maybe
two weeks ago
but
um
i um this bill originated when i was
talking last year to senator sharon
carson
who was incensed that she couldn't get
the senate to recognize that the way the
bill was crafted that came through
mandating
the public schools to have
female hygiene products on hand
uh and for them to be made available uh
for free uh based on using vending
machines in the bathrooms all bathrooms
uh she she was incensed that the the
constitutional issue here is pretty
clear in
article 28 a under mandated programs and
i won't read it to you but it passed in
and it essentially says
that
the legislature can do whatever it wants
and mandate whatever it wants it just
needs to pay for it and uh this the the
way the bill got passed
it was the
perfect storm between requiring
action on the part of the school
districts
and then insisting that there's no way
the state would pay for it so it was
almost an arrogant unfunded mandate
and
and so
i i think there's two ways that the
education committee could go on on
fixing this
uh one is hb 276 which essentially
says uh
this is not a mandate but it's a really
great suggestion you ought to do it
or
the alternative would be
to
amend it and
pay for it in which case
uh it would need to come over to finance
and we'd have to figure out how we would
pay for it
so um so that's it we there you know
if
if we mandate it as a state we have to
pay for it the current rsa
mandates it and doesn't pay for it and
it's really up to us to fix it um and
with that i'll uh i'll take questions if
there are any
thank you very much representative
edwards are there questions for
representative edwards
not
not seeing any here
thank you thank you to the education
committee and thank you for deferring
this so that i could introduce the bill
representative ladd thank you thank you
very much
next week
hi there are you able to hear me yes
great thank you good afternoon uh
chairman ladd and members of the house
education committee for the record my
name is elizabeth canada i am the
advocacy manager for planned parenthood
new hampshire action fund and planned
parenthood of northern new england and
we've submitted our testimony through
email as well
we urge you to vote itl on house bill
276.
you already know the background in 2019
this body passed senate bill 142 which
required new hampshire public high
school and middle schools to make
menstruation products available at no
cost in girls restrooms and gender
neutral restrooms
that bill passed with broad bipartisan
support and when governor sununu signed
that bill into law he said that it would
ensure students could quote learn
without disruption and free of shame or
fear of stigma end quote
house bill 276 however would no longer
require public schools to offer
menstrual products in spaces that are
accessible without students needing to
ask someone
this bill instead asks districts to make
reasonable efforts
this change would bring us back to
before the passage of senate bill 142 in
2019 and would be a major step back in
our state for menstrual equity and
reducing unnecessary
classroom disruptions
let's be clear
providing no-cost menstruation products
in public schools decreases learning
interruptions which is good for students
and good for educators and good for
schools overall i've heard mention of
costs as a prohibitive barrier for
school districts
the law went into effect in 2019
which means initial and one-time costs
for implementation were likely incurred
in 2019
additionally the law did not require
machines to be installed in bathrooms
districts and schools could provide
something as simple as a basket with
tampons and pads in restrooms
in order to enable students to practice
proper hygiene we expect schools to
supply toilet paper soap and towels or
dryers at no cost to students
we don't ask for reasonable efforts to
insure those products we expect
districts to provide them
we should similarly expect schools to
supply products needed by students who
are menstruating
in short house bill 276 would again
increase barriers for students and
barriers that will occur regularly and
monthly
the goal should be to support students
in feeling safe and comfortable in their
school buildings without feeling
stigmatized or st or singled out
new hampshire already has that law on
the books and other states and countries
have been following our lead let's not
roll back progress we ask that you vote
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
thank you very much miss canada uh are
there questions
not cnn thank you very much for hanging
in so long
thank you
abigail
hello members of the education committee
my name is abby whitcomb and i am an
alum of the londonderry school district
and i oppose hb 276.
as an 11 year old that just started her
period the summer before sixth grade i
was a bit unprepared when it came to
having it in school
and one day before lunch i ran to the
bathroom and put on a pad from the ones
provided in the bathroom i was so
embarrassed that i waited until someone
in the stall next to me flushed to open
the package because i didn't want anyone
to know that i was having a normal
bodily function that comes with puberty
the period products that were provided
helped me throughout middle school and
high school when my menstrual cycle
caught me off guard i would run to the
nurse's office between classes when i
forgotten to restock my backpack or ran
out during a cycle
for someone like me i was taught to be
ashamed of my period that having a
gigantic red stain on my pants would be
embarrassing and that i should try my
best to cover that up
i am incredibly grateful that my school
was able to help me when i was in a bind
but for students that have periods that
can't afford to buy master products the
ones that the school provides are the
only opportunity to have basic access
removing the requirement from rsa 189
colon 16a
is not acceptable
to deny students
access to basic period products because
of the cost to the district is not based
in reality
school districts across the state have
budgets upwards of millions of dollars
menstrual products are only a fraction
of a percent of the budget with that
same line of logic school districts
should not buy other sanitary products
such as toilet paper or soap or paper
towels because they cost just as much
and are just as necessary minister
products should be available to all
students who need them no exceptions
amending rsa 189 colon 16a from shall to
shall make reasonable efforts to
give schools a cop-out from providing
these products to students
if schools do not provide these products
to students because they can't find a
room in the budget students will suffer
some students will not have any access
to menstrual products at all causing
them to miss school and suffer falling
behind
others will not be able to focus on
their schoolwork because the only thing
they can focus on is not stating their
clothes
every student that menstruates will be
put at a disadvantage
hb 276 is a violation of the new
hampshire supreme court and the ruling
claremont v governor the state supreme
court has ruled that education is a
fundamental right and you as legislators
have the duty to ensure that the public
schools achieve their object and provide
an education to all its citizens that
support united support all public
schools
providing free period products
to all who need them is a crucial part
of providing an adequate education
because it keeps students from missing
school and keeps students focused on
achieving academic success
amending rsa 189 colon 16a will have an
immense impact on students across the
state and needs to be kept as is as a
former public school student i am
grateful that my school district
provided me with menstrual products when
i needed them people in period poverty
rely on schools for their products and
are even more grateful
thank you for listening to me
thank you for listening to me today and
i hope you will vote against hb 276.
thank you very much abigail are there
any questions for abigail
[Music]
not seeing any hands thank you so much
for testifying today abigail
thank you
you're welcome
okay next we
have station
good afternoon is everyone able to hear
me now
great members of the house education
committee hello i am fiona grino a
resident of meredith new hampshire and i
strongly oppose hb 276 thank you for
your time today and hearing my testimony
i am a researcher of menstrual equity
solutions with a focus on menstrual
product accessibility for students in
particular i menstruate and thus
understand how crucial menstrual
products are to each and every student
who gets their period i went to public
school in new hampshire all the way
through high school and in high school i
began an organization that raised more
than five thousand dollars worth of
menstrual products for a local shelter
to address
this need as a college student i invest
time in researching menstrual equity
there are free menstrual product
programs across the
nation in which health hygiene and
destigmatization are promoted
others have paved the way so that we may
follow their lead here in new hampshire
let me share a story one that repeats
itself every day in public schools
i was in class as a 15 year old i sat
down for a group project and felt my
period come on unexpectedly
nothing is quite like knowing that your
peers will see blood through your pants
i was supposed to be discussing
questions with my peers but instead i
was panicked embarrassing and bleeding i
asked the teacher to leave class hoping
no one would see the bloodstain i was
mortified as i walked awkwardly to my
locker all the way across school to get
a pat but i was out of pads in my locker
and i panicked once again there are a
myriad of reasons i did not go to the
nurse they were far away often out of
office had many other students to deal
with and i was already embarrassed
enough
i made a beeline to the bathroom where i
constructed an ineffective pathetic pad
out of toilet paper placing it
strategically in my underwear the only
solace was that every one of my friends
had been in this position of desperation
before
several minutes passed as i cleaned up
had been there for me i could have taken
much less time and had the comfort of
knowing i wouldn't bleed through my
pants anymore by the time i got back to
class i had missed a significant amount
of instruction and material
one thing i must make very clear
toilet paper is free in schools
therefore menstrual products should be
too
menstrual products need to be in
bathrooms so students can quickly attend
to their most basic health and hygiene
needs
no one expects a student to bring toilet
paper into school and no one would make
them get some from the nurse so why are
we making students bring their own
menstrual products in
not providing menstrual products is a
proven barrier to education those
experiencing poverty are even less
likely to have access to these products
as abby touched on earlier
here in new hampshire we know that
education is a fundamental right without
menstrual products in schools we are not
upholding this truth thank you and i
urge the committee to oppose this bill i
appreciate your time
thank you very much are there any
questions for fiona
not seeing anything very much for
testifying today
thank you
welcome
okay so um
me
there you go i got myself unneeded um
so i i continue seeing a lot of me today
i'm representing timothy oregon stratfor
county district execs the towns of
durham and madbury so i
strongly oppose this bill i think um
even though i'm uh
even though i'm a man and you know even
women my age are long past uh
menopause i still find this really an
offensive bill this is not
it's not appropriate place to put a
little lecture about article 28a this is
uh
several other people who mentioned
toilet paper these metro products are as
basic as
as basically as toilet paper um
i will say uh
i came to you a couple weeks ago with
spells about school lunch programs
actually maybe it just been last week
but it seemed like longer ago and um
that's a little bit different because
there's federal funding sort of stuff
but um
my school district has reached out to me
and the other school did reach out to me
in favor of my lunch bills nobody's ever
reached out to me to tell me to tell
kill this menstrual products hygiene
back when we passed the original bill
that created this um there was support
from the school districts so this is uh
this is as basic as
you know it's like uh
like
it'd be as if we passed a bill saying
the school district should make
reasonable efforts to ensure toilet
paper is original at all costs in all
bathrooms it's every bit as ridiculous
and as insulting as that bill would be
so i uh
you know want to have state funding i
understand the logic behind that except
of course the way the budget is
constructed that's one of those things
that would probably get slashed you know
in order just to take a few dollars out
of the budget so maybe better just let
the school districts
pay for it because they're the ones
they're the ones who are responsible for
providing the product so i i
i sort of understand the logic of having
the state do it but uh
one of those little things that would
just get whacked out of the budget at
budget time so
i i say uh
i'd say this this is a good law we
should keep it you know we should keep
it as it is and you know i'm just really
uh
really appalled that they would do it
part of it part of it
not to impugn anyone's motives or just
speculate but certainly i
as you can if you heard from other
other women who have testified uh you
know they do
there's like a subtext in there that's
that
they feel like we're playing games with
this bill just because it's not viewed
as a serious problem not as serious a
problem as problems that affected men
but for uh women
women as you've already heard this is an
extremely serious problem this is a very
simple inexpensive solution of what can
be really a very serious problem that
can lead you know that
seriously impede women's education so i
would
they keep they'll keep the bill the way
it is so
and if you
and if you do
put in state funding you have to prepare
the lobby very hard to keep it in but
next time the budget committee like
you know
small light into the budget to make it
up so uh i think
i think we've already the concerns that
this amendment just figured we're
already addressed adequately by the
original bills so um thank you very much
questions if you want to but
you've had a long day
are there any questions for
representative oregon
not seeing hands thank you very much
oh thank you
ito i'm opposed
me
welcome representative erin
didn't hear us
yes i can hear you thank you very much
sorry
for
not getting
my mute button off soon enough but
anyway good afternoon
uh education committee i'm
representative judy aaron i represent
district seven in sullivan county that's
acwrath goshen langdon lobster and
washington
just wanted to
add some extra words for what
representative edwards said when he
presented this bill
and i want to
tell the committee here today that
you have to remember
that this really this bill really has
nothing to do with menstruation or
offering products for free
what this bill is all about
is that the legislature must follow the
constitution
it's about our oath as legislators to
follow the constitution which does say
we should not be
legislating unfunded mandates
and we are doing this with this statute
in place we are exercising a power we do
not have
now i get it that people are coming and
saying how you know there's period
poverty
and there's you know it's much better if
we can offer feminine products for free
and all of that i get that i understand
it as a woman i understand it when i
went to school i had gone through the
same
problems and issues of worrying about
leaking and showing and having a problem
of not having enough product with me in
my purse i understand it i get it
but the way in which this statute stands
it is unconstitutional
and we as legislators have a duty to
repair that we must fix it
so if you want to put something in
statute
that uh men you know that that that puts
some kind of funding grant through
our our finance uh
committee or something fine go and do
that
but otherwise by pushing this
down to the school districts as an
unfunded mandate it is unconstitutional
and we must fix this
so um i understand i mean i i get
maybe there's a need for mr products
maybe there's a need to give it out for
free
i don't know if you want to compare it
to toilet paper or soap or
or napkin products whatever
that's something totally different
the issue at hand here is that as this
statute stands it is unconstitutional it
is an unfunded mandate
and we need to fix it and that's all i
have to say today thank you
thank you very much representative are
there any questions for the
representative
not seeing any hands thank you very much
have a great day
thank you
next week
maria friends
welcome to education
hi there
hello thank you again thank you for the
opportunity to speak up on
on hb 276. i testifying against this
bill
um
before i testify against this bill
i'm going to share a little bit on my
horrible story
i one of them
one of the people who started a period
not even nine years old
and then this bill
for me is like
it's gonna make embarrassing for people
like especially people from
like my background
we we don't speak up especially when we
have to walk and then ask for a man for
female products in our culture we don't
do that
we barely even like
get to speak our mothers because in our
own culture this is like something that
we don't we don't like to talk about it
this is something embarrassing do you
imagine
girls going to a guy's teachers or
someone a male
person in the school and ask for the
product
and then the other thing i
i feel so embarrassed to hear someone
supporting this bill
and saying that we should not be
giving products to the girls
it's embarrassing for someone not having
enough products when they go into school
and have an accident we should be so
important that girls make sure they have
confidence we have to build the
confidence and the girls this kind of
build is not going to build the
confidence in the girl it's going to put
the comfort down especially one that has
to go and then
expo themselves
every month when they need extra
products because they don't have the
product necessary when they have the
periods
so for for that i will ask the committee
to itl this bill
thank you very much representative are
there are are there any questions
from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you very
all much thank you very much
we have um
welcome
you
um
i'm sorry i skipped right over you thank
you so much
from aclu
sorry about that
go ahead please
good afternoon thank you i really
appreciate the opportunity to testify
again before you today my name is
jeannie herroska i'm the political
director for the aclu of new hampshire
and i'm here today in opposition to hb
276 which endangers student health and
safety
it is unsanitary and unsafe to not
regularly change tampons or pads and yet
too often students will try and make it
just make just one tampon last an entire
school day because going without means
staying home from school or utter public
humiliation
i've been trying to think all day about
how to adequately describe how
distracting and embarrassing periods can
be when a person doesn't have access to
products and it's just it's really hard
to describe
if you haven't experienced it but i can
tell you that for students who do not
have access to these products it
consumes your every hour
you're trying to pay attention to math
you're trying to pay attention to
something else and it's really hard when
the one thing at the forefront of your
mind
is your period this is something that
should
impact
schools it absolutely impacts a
student's education
um and i i do want to acknowledge that
this bill
does require schools to make quote
reasonable efforts to ensure that
menstrual products are available at no
cost to students versus hb 458 which
eliminated any obligation for schools to
do so however this bill still removes
the requirement and risks reviving
period poverty in our public schools
this legislation to be honest is
particularly distressing this year of
all years families are under
unprecedented financial hardship right
now because of the pandemic increasing
the risk of reviving period poverty if
this bill is passed
with regard to the pandemic it's also
worth noting that a lot of public
schools have been virtual either
part-time or full-time which certainly
has reduced the cost of this legislation
given that students are spending less
time in
schools so if cost is the concern it
just seems very bizarre that this is the
year that this legislation is brought
forward
and the sb 142 which was the bill passed
in 2019
was a momentous bill it was such a
positive bill for new hampshire
we all heard the governor signed it he
expressed support for it
we should stand behind that bill that
bill represented progress for student
health for student dignity and for
learning i'm urging this committee to
stand in support of that bill and to
oppose hb 276 just like we previously
asked you to oppose hb 458 i'm happy to
answer questions i really appreciate
your time and consideration this late in
the day
thank you very much mresco
are there any uh questions for mr rescue
representative
thank you mr chair thank you uh mr ruska
for your time again today
uh the aclu famously defends the
constitution famously
people's rights uh
the first amendment comes to mind
uh
could you respond please to
representative judy aaron's argument
that this is not a health issue which
which you and others seem to be blowing
on but it's simply a
constitutional issue and that sb 142 is
clearly unconstitutional
could you speak to representative
aaron's uh points please
yeah i'm happy to i i took no uh when
the representative noted that the bill
has nothing to do with menstrual
products because i very much disagree i
think this bill has everything to do
with access
uh to necessary products uh and so for
us that's what this bill is about it is
about student health and student safety
and and i can just know you know i've
been before this this committee and
other committees many many times over
the past four legislative sessions
and i hear
28 a thrown around a lot
and not very consistently i have to say
it's brought up
it seems when it's convenient and it's
sidelined when it's not
um and so to be frank i i choose to
focus on the student health and student
safety issues here because
that is
very real that is consistent we should
all care about student welfare um and so
i i defer to the committee on the 28 a
issue i just do have not seen that
consistently applied before the
legislature i have to be honest
thank you thank you very much are there
any uh further questions
not seeing any hints thank you very much
mresca
thank you
okay
next we have
valerie vermont
hi it's very nice to meet you all
virtually um my name is valerie vellante
i'm an ob gyn resident physician here in
the state of new hampshire
um
i
want to just testify very strongly
against this bill hb 276 as an ob gyn i
meet with teenagers i meet with you
every day and one of the biggest
complaints that i have is is periods and
how they're embarrassing but also how
they're heavy and it keeps them from
school
one in five teenagers in the u.s will
miss class somewhere in the middle
school high school period because of
lacks lack of access to proper
period products tampons pads um i had a
patient yesterday who
is so she's you know she's 25
and she recounted so eloquently for me
that her senior year of high school she
missed 80 years sorry 80 days of school
because of her period um taking away
menstrual products for women which are
as fundamental i know that it was said
it's not as fundamental as toilet paper
and so but it's a bodily function it's
normal
we shouldn't feel ashamed in a but
the way our society functions is we do
feel ashamed as women because of
menstruation
which is a normal function it's no
offense how we all came to exist in this
world without menstruation we wouldn't
have con you know conception we wouldn't
be here
i think that is fundamentally what we
have to remember
taking away this bill taking away access
of of girls in seoul to have free
period products um raises the issue of
gender equality implies that women are
you know treated less than men that we
don't need to give them the same access
to fundamental human supplies as men you
know we wouldn't take away men's toilet
paper why take away women's period
products so
um i greatly appreciate to me i greatly
appreciate you supporting um
the removal of the bill proposal i said
that a little backwards um happy to
answer any questions that you have for
me
thank you very much mr lent uh are there
any more
sorry
hillary can you repeat your last name
yep um so i'm i'm a physician um and my
last name is valant v is in victor
a-l-a-n-t
and i specialize in obstetrics and
gynecology
thank you
thank
you mind if you take questions
absolutely i would love questions
represent like this
oh i forgot what i was gonna ask um
my question
has to do with um
do you i guess
what i keep hearing and i'm wondering if
you had input on
is um
because it takes the mandate away
absolutely will supply and just says
reasonable efforts
to ensure
do you believe that that will then
schools will just eliminate um
carrying the period private period
products
thank you um i think that's a good
question i think wording is very
important in bills like this um i think
from what i've been hearing throughout
the day as i've been stepping in and out
of clinic is that school budgets are
really tough and they're tight and i
think people look for ways to
to
be able to achieve budgets in a system
that is confronted right the public
education system
needs constant work and i think if you
take out language
that allows for the option of supplying
them without mandating it
then it could be something that goes by
the wayside and it's not going to be
provided and it's unfair
that a product that women need for a
natural function of their bodies is not
supplied by the schools
thank you thank you very much
thank you very much valerie are there
further questions from mrs valance i i
guess it's dr belan it is thank you for
the correction i appreciate it sorry
doctor um
for further further questions
thank you very much
thank you
okay so next we have um
are you out there megan
hi good afternoon sorry about that i
swear every time i get called my um
my zoom goes out on me um so i apologize
for that but thank you mr chair um and
members of the committee for the record
my name is megan tuttle i'm president
for nea new hampshire um
representing about 17 000 educators
across the state of new hampshire um i
know that a lot of this might sound
repetitive from what you've already
heard but i think it does bear repeating
um based on what this bill is talking
about so last year we know a bill was
passed and signed by governor sununu to
make available free feminine products
feminine hygiene products in all girl
and gender neutral bathrooms in middle
schools and high schools across new
hampshire that involved getting the
products and involved possibly buying
and putting up vending machines or other
places for those products to be
displayed the reason for this was not
because it's something girls want it's
something girls need i think we need to
be clear that without the original
provisions in the law all the female
students do become second class citizens
it's been shown and we talked about this
last year that girls are missing on
average some of them 40 days of school a
year due to not having access to
feminine hygiene products that's over a
month of school that's a lot um and if
you think about it it's not because they
want to miss school they're missing it
because they don't have access to these
products
it's not like the girls want to have
their period every month but they do is
we've heard testimony from people before
me it's it's just something that we have
feminine hygiene products are considered
luxury items so it's not like they can
be purchased with the use of snap funds
this bill is trying to take this back by
saying that schools only have to use
reasonable effort to ensure menstrual
hygiene products are available and this
is just being called an unfunded mandate
but there's nothing that i can see in
here that says the state has to pay for
it it says that they can the district
shall seek or the districts may seek
reimbursement but nothing saying the
state would have to reimburse them and
that's wrong the the the law is already
there the districts need to provide this
and that's what we need to stick with
seeking reimbursement because the
district has refused to honor its
responsibility to provide for the basic
needs of half their students is a best
and insulting second place trophy female
students are missing class time and
they're being robbed of the sequel
education
it's applying toilet paper we hear a lot
about this and it sounds silly but it's
true that's not considered an unfunded
mandate schools have to provide
receptacles to put the feminine hydrogen
products in so they know that they're
needed
again it sounds silly but it really is
the same principle
districts provide meals districts pay
for water districts pay for heat they
pay for all basic human essential needs
except this one and they need to elected
leaders far too long have ignored
women's issues they've denied them equal
access and they've proud that there just
isn't money to pay for things basically
what we're hearing is females is you're
not a priority you're not even close to
being one
other states passing similar laws we
were one of the first in the nation to
do this last year and other states took
our lead scotland as a country has free
feminine hygiene products for their
entire country a whole country we always
hear about other countries and their
studies about education and how they got
kids back into school why don't we look
at studies about free feminine hygiene
products for the entire country instead
of just in our state and squabbling over
whether districts should have to pay for
them or not
um
in new hampshire is in opposition to
this bill we don't want girls missing
valuable time in schools because of a
equity issue like this and there's no
reason to change the law that's already
in place
um thank you for hearing the testimony
and i'm more than willing to take any
questions and i will be sending in the
written testimony for you
thank you very much mr
for megan
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you
uh next we have someone named debbie
and i like that thing very
welcome to education
hello can you hear me
yeah
okay good all right um my name is debbie
green i'm a constituent in greenville
new hampshire and i just have a couple
of questions as i am fairly new to
politics and i'm getting to understand
how things work
so this bill
seems to be suggesting
that the school districts need to find a
way
to pay for these products on their own
and that
may get reimbursement they may not
and
so that leads me to believe then that
what about the very poor school
districts who have a hard time affording
what they already have
they are not going to be provided for
so just please give me some
clarification on that if you would
i see that represent edwards is still
on the pump there maybe he could answer
that
hold on one minute
okay
hey edwards we have someone who has a
question on the bill would should be
available
for answers
i'd be happy to answer any questions
okay okay jimmy would you please repeat
what your question was
oh sure okay so this bill seems to be
suggesting to me
that it's going to be placed upon school
districts to pay for these products and
then to
seek reimbursement or scrounge around
from
i think i read other like non-profit
organizations who might help donate that
sort of thing
and that just makes me wonder then what
about the very poor school districts who
have a hard time
already affording things and teachers
have to
pay money you know out of their own
pocket for some of the supplies does
does this mean that
they just don't get any
well thank you for the question i i
would say that um
by and large what you're describing is
the law as it currently exists
the law as it currently exists directs
the schools to come up with the funding
to pay for
the supplies
and it doesn't allow
the the school districts to come back
to the state to request any funds
and so
the issue here
really isn't about the the item that
we're talking about it's the
constitutional prohibition
of the state legislature
directing action on the part of a local
school district without also paying for
that action it's it's an easy
constitutional principle that i think
any first-year lawyer could explain
i don't remember ever allowing a member
of the public to question the
sponsor of a bill
during the hearings like this
in this particular situation we usually
have people that are technicians from
various departments and we've also asked
at times when the representatives the
prime sponsor bill and this was a
question regarding the the bill itself
and representative edwards was kind
enough to
try to help him respond it's not a
committee to respond in that because
we're not the makers of that bill
you may go ahead
so thank you mr chairman i i think i've
reached the conclusion of the answer i i
don't know if it was adequate to the
person who asked
i i i did have a question for you before
the session ends
do we have any more uh
this this debbie green thank you very
much debbie uh for coming and testifying
today
um
representative edwards if you have a
question to ask me uh go ahead
yes sir i'm sorry it really isn't a
question as much as just a a a
professional courtesy
to let you know that i'll be
filing a complaint with the
speaker's house or speaker's office
relative to what the representative from
durham did during his testimony before
the committee as an experienced state
representative i believe
that
he knew or should have known
he was misrepresenting my testimony and
my bill
and he did so in an intentionally
derogatory and
insulting manner
in order to mock or diminish
the substance of what we're talking
about okay so
i just wanted to let you know i'll i'll
be filing the complaint sir
on any business of the committee what
this representative does go ahead and do
it
yes
our job your
yes sir it was a professional courtesy
to let you know that's what i'm going to
be doing that's not how i want to
interpret
i don't think you were recognized either
representative i'm a member of the
committee representative you are not
okay i think that all of us it's the end
of our day here um
let's try to end it amongst ourselves
here in a point manner if we can amongst
our own committee here
and represent edwards can and can he's a
representative he can file an accordance
with the procedures spelled out for him
um that's not my business or your
business right now it may be who knows
but it's let's move on as the last
reminder folks remember we do have
we're going to close this down first um
we have here on
this is uh hb 276.
i believe we must have close to 11
people testifying on this why don't you
rip some hobson and represent shaw
give us the update here 13
okay 13 testifying we had done 20 in
support
uh 282 opposed to neutral
um
the individuals were the support of the
school board manhattan
school administrators association and
the new hampshire school board
association
they were not available at the time
yes they were the only ones that had
signed up amongst other people that were
not here
so i want to thank everybody for
participating today i recognize that i
apologize for this going so very very
long today um especially on a date we're
supposed to be out there and municipal
government doing our things
so thank you very much and reminder that
we do have a meeting coming up on
thursday where we will be exacting uh
bills which are noted in the calendar
and also please remember that we can
exact other bills which we previously
heard
so in conclusion i'm going to call this
meeting to an end and thank everybody
for participating today have a great
evening
night